Two,
two,
two.
I'm here with confirmed cosmin.
Not Steve.
Oh yeah man.
Who's been to space a man who knows
about the atmosphere.
I can't say I've been to space.
I went up and a Russian Mig fighter jet
to the edge of the earth's atmosphere
high.
Was that.
Do you know how I fucking forget shit.
I fucking forget.
But it wasn't that much higher than a
normal flight is like.
And then what's like,
I've heard the gun go higher,
right?
They can go up to like 35,000 for
commercial flight.
I want to say that,
that,
that it might've been like,
not much more than 50,000,
but I,
I,
I can't back that up.
I don't remember.
Maybe it was shockingly less than you
would imagine.
Oh,
that's.
You had a video of it.
Does it show this wild boys?
Oh no shit going straight up right
there.
They used a lot of,
uh,
they used a lot of stock footage,
but at the same time,
on the way down this motherfucker did
Toros and fuck it was,
it wasn't like the gnarliest
rollercoaster ride ever.
And,
and this is me filming myself like at
that.
Oh my God,
it's fucking night up there.
Wow.
That's,
that shows for anybody wants to say the
fucking world is flat.
That's fucking prove motherfuckers.
Well,
you can see the curvature of the earth.
Wow.
That's nuts.
And so when you were doing this,
um,
did,
did you get ghost close to blacking out?
Like how has the course?
Um,
I didn't get close to black men or
anything like that.
And uh,
I,
I thought that that it would be one
thing.
What it was was I was just fucking
claustrophobic.
Madison cramped in this tiny little.
I get claustrophobic.
I didn't like that.
Did you do,
did they tell you how many g forces you
were doing?
High.
That's another thing.
I can't remember.
But,
uh,
I feel like there was more g shit going
on when we did the,
uh,
the zero gravity plane,
which,
uh,
you know,
it just kind of goes along and then it
does a big bell curve kind of deal with
siggy you become weightless and uh,
that one you could feel yourself really
like being pulled down with the gs or
whatever.
I did a flight with the F,
a teen with the blue angels wants.
Oh,
they took me up and the,
they take out as you go down to San
Diego and then you travel east like
through the desert.
It's weird and I don't know which air
force bases out there.
It's like real close to,
I guess close to Arizona or maybe even
in Arizona.
But uh,
we got to seven and a half gs.
We were doing these crazy things where
you go like through these mountain
ranges and you're only like a hundred,
maybe 200 feet off the ground
turning and twisting and fucking
bananas.
Dude,
dude.
So they took you up and wild boys.
And what year was this?
Was okay.
We were
cool with the Russians then,
right?
That was 2005.
Yeah.
Two thousand five.
That was our last ever wild boys trip.
Yeah.
And uh,
we brought Knoxville with us.
Knoxville.
We had some,
uh,
like Russian army kind of dudes.
And the Knox was like,
shoot me with the nine millimeter gun
with the rubber bullet while the dog
bites me why he was,
he was going for it.
And,
and,
and uh,
our director Jeff Tremaine was like,
hey,
if you still have this in you,
why don't we not do it for TV?
Let's make another movie.
And that was why we stopped doing wild
boys and made Jack as number two.
If you still have this in,
you want to get beaten down with rubber
bullets,
when do we have a lot of shit happened
on that.
Fuck.
On that last wild boys trip,
man,
there is a that we always,
we had this practice of like,
um,
for the sensors,
you know,
it's called standards and practices.
They'll be like,
they'll give back notes,
like you can't show this.
And so we would film what we call red
herrings,
like just blatantly ridiculous shit is
never like never going to be allowed on
TV.
But then we'll be like,
okay,
well we'll cut this out and so then
we'll be able to keep some other shit.
So we would always go out of her way to
fill in this fucked up stuff.
And in Russia we,
um,
me and one of the guys from the,
from the crew should put like put on
these animals suits the um,
what was it at the time,
it wasn't panda bears with polar bears
with the big fucking like mascot head.
And we fucking hired two hookers and had
full on fucking hookers came in like
full porno.
We felt like full fucking porno.
I went included to be included that in
the episode I had the notes came back
from standards and practices.
I can really pleased.
I got that.
You have to take out the,
you know,
the COC,
soccer.
We had the polar bear getting his dick
sucked like that.
The whole thing.
And Yeah.
And,
and there were,
there was a little bit of fucking hooker
action in that one,
you know,
and I'm not necessarily that stoked
about it,
but,
um,
there was uh,
we went to a,
went to like a whorehouse,
brought this hooker back to the hotel
right there,
like a whole thing and then in,
in,
in the,
and,
and I don't think I ever could have sex
with a,
with a hooker without like snuggling
after I want to like snipe snuggle and
studying it on,
like I wanted to stay with me.
I want to like,
you know,
cuddle and stuff.
And in the morning this,
this hooker,
um,
she just tells me how much,
how much I owe her.
And I'm like,
that's fucking outrageous.
There's no fucking way I was.
I was like,
basically,
I don't care if you're a fucking pimp,
wants to kick my ass and fucking kill
me.
I'm not paying that fucking much.
I forget it was so long ago.
But,
uh,
but yeah,
I was outraged beforehand.
It,
it just,
it just wasn't in that case.
I remember clearly.
I like,
do you want that mentioned?
I said,
I'll give you this much,
and that's how much he get,
period.
And we,
we,
we came out,
right?
Like,
um,
you know,
I got to go film and uh,
well I can through the lobby.
Knoxville is down there having
breakfast.
This hooker comes walking by and knocks
on.
She says,
that's not Steve.
Oh,
that's cheap bowl.
I was never even that much into like
hookers,
but,
um,
you know,
in,
in looking back on it,
I guess I really fucking kind of had sex
with a bunch of hookers because,
um,
I had this girlfriend and um,
you know,
like I work at like a program of
recovery.
I got to be honest and shit.
And I had this girlfriend,
she was an English chick and she says,
um,
have you ever had sex with a prostitute?
And I'm like,
Oh fuck,
you know,
and I tell her,
uh,
what's the,
you know,
I never did until I was in,
in,
in England one time.
And uh,
you know,
there's,
we did this gumball rally where you race
cars,
all the rich guys.
And uh,
yeah,
they're getting hugs and they got me one
and,
and I brought her to the uts.
I told her the whole story about how I
was,
I can't give me a massage and she's
giving me a back rub and the hooker says
this is one expensive back rub.
And I felt like she was making fun of me
and I said,
fuck it.
And I put on Motley crue and put on a
rubber and humped her.
Okay.
You know,
I told this story to my girlfriend.
She says,
I said,
okay,
what uh,
did you,
uh,
was there any other ones?
I'm like,
ah,
fuck,
you know,
I'm like,
well,
in New Zealand you know,
like there was a massage parlor and it
turned out that,
that they just have sex with you,
you know,
like,
and it's a joke.
I,
you know,
it's like I didn't feel like I felt like
it was having sex with a prostitute,
but she was a misuse,
like another one.
I'm like,
wow,
there's a time in Indonesia.
So it just kept rolling off.
Yeah.
And the thing was that at that exact
time we were,
she'd like,
she arranged this trip to go to
cornwall.
Uh,
it's a little surf town in England
because I like collect pictures with a,
you know,
of the different countries where the
united,
I call it my surf passport and I'm like,
I want to get a surfing photo so I can
include England.
She's like,
she says,
I know why you're making it sort of
passport.
You should have a fucking hooker
It's so funny to like driving over here.
I was,
I was like thinking man,
fucking so nervous about going on,
on,
you know,
Joe Rogan's podcast because how can I
touch the last time it was so epic,
like there's never been another
interview that I've ever done that has
gotten that.
I've gotten more feedback.
Like people just being like,
dude,
I fucking heard that.
Like people were like inspired people
who are struggling with substance abuse
and they're like,
man,
like,
that helped.
Helped me get sober.
Like Howard Stern,
like,
you name it.
Any interview I've ever done in my life,
like it has.
This has been the one that I,
the I hear about the most and then I get
the most positive feedback.
Fucking grateful deed for that man.
I'm grateful for you coming on and you
can't compare yourself to yourself
though.
Don't ever do that.
Okay.
I get that,
but it'll get you every time I get that.
I know.
I saw that.
Like on Jim Jefferies,
a Jim Jeffrey does.
I think he even did that on his,
on his special.
He's like all this special isn't as good
as my last specialty.
He said that on this special.
Right.
But that's the thing like I'm not gonna
do that too much,
but in the moment,
right in the moment.
Stephen,
thank you for that Joe Guy.
I'm pretty,
pretty good about that but.
But I should say and I can like get in
my head and I'm not going to trip myself
out,
but I did want to come in hot so I just
fucking came out with the hooker story
going from edge of space.
The earth isn't cloud dude,
firemen and pot.
Chris Ponti is my wild boys coastguard
guy.
I remember at one point saying something
to the effect of like,
ah,
you know,
like I'm an astronaut,
I,
and,
and pawnee is,
if I can nailed me so hard,
is so fucking funny.
He says,
he says,
uh,
you're not,
not a virgin because you'd go to the
edge of the girl's vagina.
Good point.
Right?
He kind of had to cross the goal line.
What was more dangerous doing jackass or
doing wild boys had to be wild boys.
That's what I was in times over man,
because I watched jackass and I go,
wow,
these guys are so crazy.
But I watched wild boys and literally my
asshole just tight.
And so dude,
my toes curl,
start clenching my hands together.
I can't do.
I don't know how the fuck you guys did
it and got away with it,
right?
There's no question man.
Like a fucking lions.
Tigers,
bears venomous reptiles.
Yeah.
When that lion climbed a tree and beat
your fucking hat,
here's the thing,
right?
And here's the thing.
And,
and,
and there is a distinction about this
jackass for completely fade there.
There's so much integrity and jackass
Knoxville like would not ever people
says is the stuff you do real fuck adds
real 100 percent.
And with wild boys there is no,
uh,
I mean,
what you see is it happened,
but what we were dishonest about with
wild boys is like locations.
We would pretend that we were in Africa
when really they had this fucking,
uh,
in California,
there's a company called like a
Hollywood animals,
right?
Where they've got like a,
you know,
whatever.
They've got the fucking lions and the
Tigers and shit.
Now when we went over to Africa the
first time we brought the zebra suit,
every intention of being on safari
playing around in front of lions,
but that just wasn't in the cards.
They're like,
no,
that's not gonna happen.
So we kill you.
But yeah,
we found that.
We found this great whole thing going
through the safari to Mansi pursuit.
But the only way we could get the end
was to come back to California.
And I remember Jay Leno fucking caught
called.
This happened the first time we went on
the Jay Leno show to promote wild boys.
He says,
you know,
I walk into the dressing room,
you,
I said,
I watched that,
uh,
that um,
lion clip with the two Mansi pursuit and
thinking,
you know,
I've never seen gravel like that,
in Africa on the ground.
And he says,
the way that the line went for the Zebra
head,
the Ca,
the,
he said,
no part of that.
Nope.
No part of that lion wants that fake
zebra head,
you know,
it doesn't make sense.
And uh,
and he was so right.
He nailed it.
One hundred percent.
He's like,
I'm guessing what,
what they did was they rubbed some kind
of shit on the zebra,
had to attract the line to it and he
just broke it down.
You know,
I'd,
I have,
the last thing I want to do is be a
fucking fan of Jay Leno,
but he was a good God.
You did.
Okay.
He is,
I'm telling you,
man,
he just seems weird because he did the
tonight show for so long.
Ah,
okay.
And I'm not trying to like just
piggyback on Howard Stern being the
stern fan,
but,
uh,
I don't know.
I got a weird vibe by myself from,
from Jay Leno,
but I'll take your word for it.
What impressed the shit out of me with
that calling out that line.
But what weird vibe did you get home?
You don't know,
like,
uh,
I just felt like for all the times that
we were guests or that I was on his
show,
I just felt like A.
I don't know,
is it?
Yeah,
I think it's fair to say felt like maybe
a little bit todd talked down to in a
way I felt like sorta.
I like,
I like the impression that I got was
that whoever booked us on the show
wasn't him and that he was sort of like
under protest,
like,
you know,
maybe I'm just,
he was sort of under protest for almost
everything that was on his show.
Right.
It was really a mess.
Look,
Jay Leno started out as one of the top
stand up comics in the world.
He was a fucking killer.
He was a young guy who would go on
letterman and he was edgy and this is
like,
you know,
19 seventies or early 19 eighties,
whatever.
And then he got the tonight show and
when he got the tonight show,
he became a tonight show host and he
never put out.
He doesn't still to this day,
it doesn't put out any standup.
You can't see it anywhere other than my
tonight show.
Mommy blogs.
He does it every week,
but he does the same act.
Ah Shit.
Yeah,
he doesn't change his shit.
It's real weird.
He's a weird guy.
But what his real.
I mean he's still a great comic,
but his real passion is cars.
Like if you're a car guy and you go over
to his place,
you get to see the real Jay Leno and Oh,
you should've been doing like I did his
show to a Jay Leno's garage.
I was like,
you should have been doing this the
whole time.
Why did you even fuck with the tonight
show?
Like you're,
you're a fucking monster when it comes
to cars.
He's fun.
He's loose,
he knows everything about cars.
You get to see the him.
He
lights up.
I remember we were promoting a jackass.
Three d on the tonight show.
Went over there and we did the tee ball
thing,
right,
like where it's like a tee ball but it's
got an arm and he hit it and then swing
it hits me in the nuts and,
and we did it.
I think it was like during rehearsal or
so we did it like during rehearsal fully
hit me in the nuts or so,
and I wanted to demonstrate that I
wasn't wearing a cup.
Right.
And I had these tidy whities on and I
and I fucking pulled down my tighty
whities to show it was just my dick,
but he didn't really need to do.
I'm part of the problem.
He's so old school and,
and uh,
that's the,
I see it clearly now and he said it,
he goes,
it looks like a dick.
Just a lot smaller,
but I that,
that was just part of A.
I don't know,
that's just part of where I got that
vibe from him.
But the last thing I don't want to feel
like,
I know what you mean.
And then there was a dollar dispute with
him and Howard Stern.
Sure.
Because like,
what was it going on?
Like writers were taken bits from stern
and doing it on.
Right.
I can't even remember at this.
Howard so hated Johnny Carson too,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
you know what,
man,
that's one of those things where a lot
of those guys,
you know,
especially like if you have a platform
like Howard,
you feel distraught by.
Some guys got another platform with fuck
this guy tell to go to war.
She was.
Howard's whole thing was about conflict.
Conflict is ratings.
He was the king of ratings with Jay Leno
and Howard.
It was personal with,
with Howard and cars and I think he was
just.
Howard had the impression that Carson
was a bad dude.
I don't know.
I think he had a personal thing.
I'm maybe I'm just making that up,
but I'm telling you man,
I knew Jay from the tonight show and
knew Jay from when I was on NBC.
I've seen him on here with you too,
dude.
He was great on here.
The stories about like doing standup for
the mob shows.
I've seen some psychopath mob guy at a
priest did.
They were great.
Fucking,
hey dude,
I fucking,
I recant anything negative said about
Jayla plus I should say I'm fucking
grateful it's Jay Leno because he had,
you know,
I never,
I was never on Letterman.
No.
Yeah.
What was the thing too,
with those dudes?
If you did one,
you couldn't do the other unless you're
like,
you know,
someone who's like a humongous star.
Yeah,
those shows suck.
They're really do.
They're just not.
No,
no disrespect to them,
but those five minute things,
we sit on the couch,
then you cut to the next thing.
It's just right.
It's just a shitty way to get to know
somebody and it's gone downhill from
there because all anybody gives a fuck
about is what's gonna,
you know,
take off on the Internet the next day.
Exactly.
They're not even,
they're not even focused on anything
except some fucking gimmick.
That's gonna some highlight reel clip,
right?
Yeah.
Did you see the whole bear thing where
he went off on trump?
I couldn't fucking believe it.
I was watching it.
I was like,
I and I,
I tweeted about this,
that I don't think kids today have any
idea how strange it is to watch a talk
show host.
Call the president's mouth a cock
holster.
Okay.
This is talking about the president.
I mean,
I know it's tunneled trump,
but it's still the president.
There's weird.
There's a lot of weird stuff going on.
And then did you see a Koala bear
responding to trump's response?
That made me uncomfortable.
Why?
I'm sure people don't want to even hear
about it.
No,
please do.
It made me uncomfortable where he's
like,
I won and you know,
I mean it's,
it's again,
it's just playing into,
you know,
what,
what can I do?
What he said was he got trumped to
response trying to get.
He was trying to get the president to
say his name for so long and he finally
did and it was what he said was that I
thought you of all the things that I
thought you were dumb about,
the one thing that I thought you knew
about with show business,
I thought you understood showbiz.
So like,
I was trying to get you to respond and
you did.
So I win,
right?
Which is just.
Okay.
So now the president didn't.
This is even weird because weirder
because now the president is responding
to a guy who's essentially saying that
he's a fucking troll.
I mean Steven Cole Bear multimillionaire
talk show host on a major network,
took over the letterman spot is now
admitting that he's essentially like a
guy on twitter.
There's a fucking egg icon.
I think that that might've been what
made me feel uncomfortable,
just low level,
super low level,
low level.
And,
and,
and uh,
it wasn't like all this stuff that trump
was saying about how they were going to
take them off and they're gonna know the
guy coordinator came after they were
going to put James Corden into Koala
bears time slot.
Like,
I mean,
the other reports I saw were that they
were trying to get cold,
bear the fuck out,
and then all of a sudden he started
slamming trump and now he's like number
one out of everybody in late night.
Well,
that's how it goes.
And that stupid fucking business.
They just have to get people to pay
attention to them and sometimes that's
the way to do it.
I mean,
maybe Cole bear just got Desperado,
but it's the whole thing is so fucking
strange.
Like Kobe or strange man.
He's like a hardcore Catholic,
hardcore,
which is even weirder that he's calling
the president's mouth a cock holster.
Was a hardcore Catholic.
Where do your,
where your standard Sli,
like where you,
uh,
where do you draw that line?
Right.
It's not very Catholic,
have you?
It's like the guy from megadeath,
the lead singer megadeath became like a
super hardcore Christian really and now
won't sing some of his songs.
Get the fuck you and he won't perform
with some certain death metal bands.
Come on,
God,
come right back.
A fantastic man.
There's something happens.
I don't know if you noticed this,
but something happens that I've been
noticing.
As you know,
I'm almost 50.
I'll be 50 in August.
Did bless your heart.
Bless your heart.
I'll be,
I'll be 43 next month.
Two to just creeps up on.
You did timely.
As faster as it goes by if.
Well,
you know what it is,
it's like your reference to time is
different because when you're six,
a year is a sixth of your life.
When you're 49,
it's like another year.
It's like also you're busy as fuck.
So the days keep moving.
Quick reference time.
I think it also goes by faster.
It seems like it goes by faster,
right?
You have more of them to think about.
I had a bit that I was working on for
the long time.
I don't know if I'm going to resurrect
it,
but the premise is that God must hate
us.
Premise why she'd be dead.
Loved one.
No,
no.
You'd be suffering.
Think about you'll live in lack of a
Steevo.
How could that hit?
Got Hit you.
He loves you.
Right?
Right.
Well,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's broken comedy,
right?
I mean,
it makes sense though,
right?
Sure.
And,
and I back it up,
dude.
I back it up.
They do that a kit now we're the only
living organism,
right?
They can watch and have an opinion of
itself wilting.
Right.
That's a good point.
It's a fucking really good point.
You know,
a fucking bananas not looking in the
mirror saying off,
fuck,
I'm bruising the sides.
Like I don't look as good as I did
fucking,
you know,
I'm going to rot and.
But what's really weird is when you
watch,
do you watch videos of yourself from a
long time ago and you see how different
you look?
Yes.
But I think uh,
uh,
have a lot of people I like pretty
fucking.
I look less like,
less different than other people and now
I get like super sensitive about like,
you know,
if I posted a picture on lines and
motherfuckers,
Oh,
do you know,
like,
shit effect it effects like I wish it
didn't but it does,
man.
I'm a fucking sensitive guys.
Motherfuckers old.
But now I got,
now I got a uh,
a project that I'm working on where,
where I'm digging up like old ass
footage and I'm looking at it.
I'm thinking I don't look that much
different.
Fuck all these people,
you know,
maybe you're delusional.
I may look younger for sure.
But like,
uh,
it was,
there was a,
I don't know,
like I fucking,
well you've kept your body in reasonable
shape,
your engagement,
your healthy.
That was real issues when people
balloon.
I looked at Kathleen Turner.
Do you remember?
Kathy went to my high school in London,
England.
Dude,
she was so hot when she was young and
now she's like,
right,
like she's got that alcoholic face where
people don't just get older but
everything sort of balloons.
And you know,
your,
your cheeks balloon in your Chin
balloons.
Sure.
All swelling.
And it's crazy to like I went to high
school all four years in London,
England at the American School in
London,
England and there's only called the
American school,
the American School in London,
England.
So I don't have an accent because
everyone was just American
at this school in my neighborhood.
I'm really.
So it was actually everyone at the
school was in England.
They have like different fucking kind of
high school.
It's that guy.
It's not grades,
it's like forms.
He graduated and when you're 16 it's all
different curriculum.
But this is in England,
in London.
And you take your sats,
you have like American African American.
It's an American school in London.
Yeah.
Your folks were living in England folks?
Correct?
I grew up in five different countries.
Did you really?
Yeah.
I was born in England and uh,
when I was six months old and moved to
Brazil and my family moved to Brazil.
It's like,
it's no one would ever fucking gets
this.
But my dad was like a baller ass
corporate executive real.
And when I was six months old my family
moved to Brazil because my dad,
I became the president of Pepsi Cola in
all of Brazil.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
So he did.
So they ever fucking had shit going on,
like they live in maids and um,
I was raised by fucking like these
Brazilian servants that lived,
that lived in the house.
So I spoke my first word in Portuguese.
Wow.
My,
my parents didn't.
My parents just didn't fucking pay
attention to me.
So that's what made you crazy perhaps.
Yeah.
They deal with you now.
Um,
while my mom died in 2003 and my dad and
I are fucking tight as fuck everything.
That was cool.
Yeah,
everything that the drove apart brought
us together and spoke my first words in
Portuguese in Brazil when I was two
years old I moved to Venezuela and I
spoke fluent Spanish in nursery school
in Caracas,
Venezuela.
Holy Shit.
When I was four years old and moved to,
to uh,
Connecticut.
So by the time I was three,
I spoke three languages fluently.
By the time I was five I forgot to have
them completely.
And then when I was six years old we
moved to Miami when I was nine years
old.
Moved to London,
England when I was 12 years old,
moved to Canada,
lived in Toronto and then 13 years old
back to England and I stayed there all
through high school.
Wow.
So this is all your dad just being an
effort,
different companies within the moved
from Brazil to Venezuela.
Dad got promoted to fuck.
Or the president of Pepsi Cola in South
America I think maybe like maybe all of
South America.
I'm not sure.
Then when we moved to,
uh,
to Connecticut,
I want to say that's when dad became a
fucking a big tobacco CEO.
Whoa.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
Smoke.
Um,
he never fucking took a puff on a
cigarette in his life ever because an
executive I fucking didn't do dad sold
soda,
Pepsi Bucket and just sugar water than
cigarettes.
And then when we,
when we were living in Miami,
this is the 19 eighties and all the
sudden it came to light that cigarettes
were bad for you and right.
And all the tobacco companies started
buying up food companies,
you know,
because it's thinking,
fuck,
we got to get out,
we to get out of this.
And so my dad worked for Rjr,
which is a tobacco company and Rjr,
Rj Reynolds,
what?
It was rj reynolds and they bought
Nabisco and the companies merged.
It became Rjr Nabisco and that dad had
an aberration only good year that year
that,
that ended up becoming like the
president of Nabisco and shit.
Wow.
Yeah.
I forget if it was,
um,
I don't really know what they didn't
figure out until the 19 eighties and
cigarettes are bad for you.
They only really only became a legal
issue in the eighties,
like lawsuits and shit.
Right.
They,
they,
they only really got fucking scared of
lawsuits in the eighties.
You know what's crazy?
I just read something about tobacco
companies that they're making more money
now than ever that less people smoke,
but they charge more for cigarettes now
than they ever have before.
Oh my God.
Australia in Australia,
it's 20 fucking dollars a pack.
What?
Twenty fucking dollars.
A pack of $20 American or $20.
Australian trillion.
$20 Australian exchange,
right?
It's full of parody to the Canadian
dollar.
So pretty close to our one.
One Australian dollar is seventy five
cents,
um,
for,
for American students.
So fucking funny.
I was over there and I've done a couple
of Australia,
a few Australia tours and I went in
there,
they got the fucking cigarettes locked
up.
Like you can't even see them.
They're in a fucking,
like a gun cabinet.
You gotta you gotta ask them to unlock
the gun cabinet,
which you can't even see into.
And then like it's illegal for them to
even have a fucking,
uh,
a logo.
Like there's no logo,
there's no,
nothing like even the name like
Marlboro.
They don't,
they can't use the brand name of
Marlboro every fucking cigarettes.
Uh,
the name of the company has to be in the
same fucking font.
They can't even,
they can't even have the Marlboro logo
or font.
It's all a uniform of font that says the
company and the entire fucking pack is
just the most.
The whole fucking packaging is nothing
but one gigantic photo of like a dead
baby.
The most hilarious fucking like shit.
And I'm telling you that.
And it's $20 per pack and everybody's
fucking smoking.
I think that's the craziest thing about
it,
is it the more that they charge more
than ever.
And there you go.
Full screen with Jesus Christ.
That causes blindness.
Folks that were going,
I'd spoken causes throat and mouth
cancer brand.
Same brand in the same fucking font.
Why am I so fucking hilarious?
Lapsed doesn't work,
dude.
It doesn't keep people from buying at
and t,
I mean,
imagine that.
Imagine picking up a new pack.
Everything that is so fucking bizarre.
They got straight as he got dead babies.
They gotTa fucking Causes Emphysema.
Grandma Frankie knows every single one
of them is so fucking hilarious.
Yeah,
I've never seen that.
I've seen in England they have a big
picture of like people that have lung
cancer and shit on the cover it says
smoking will kill you,
but they don't have this shit.
What the fuck causes peripheral vascular
disease?
It makes your feet rot.
Gang Green Day was the most team picture
I saw on a pack of cigarettes was um,
it was a picture of a toilet with blood
in the water and I forget what the point
was on that one.
But cigarettes make your asshole bleed.
Isn't that crazy?
That,
that doesn't even work.
Like you're selling someone something
that you're showing them all the
terrorists shit that it could do.
And everybody's like,
yeah,
worth it.
Right where the front pipe.
I know,
I used to be convinced.
I remember Dr Dre,
Dr Dre used to Pester me to try and get
me on that celebrity rehab show before I
was sober and he had another project
which was trying to,
uh,
it was focused on getting people to quit
smoking cigarettes.
Were you smoking at the time?
I smoked for fucking 17 years.
I started smoking when I was 16 and
stopped when I was 33.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Seventeen years.
I fucking smoked man.
Do you feel any ill effects of it now?
Forty three.
Uh,
almost 43.
And how's your cardio?
I think it's pretty good.
What fucked up my cardio was all that
nitrous oxide dude.
I thought that material.
I went and I went through,
there was whippet cartridges.
There's 24 per box and there's 25 boxes
per case.
So per case there's 600 cartridges and
it was not unusual for me to go through
624 hour,
24 to 36 hours.
I went and I took every measure to try
to limit like the fucking air that went
into my lungs to try to make it like all
nitrogen oxide.
Like I was the whole time I'm holding,
I'm holding in a long flow of that shit
and I'm just with my fucking camp,
the canister from starbucks and Shannon.
I was like a fucking wizard at like
loading up six until while holding the
last fucking ones,
you know,
and,
and dear.
That was when all the crazy shit would
go down because that would be like awake
on cocaine for three days and inhaling
nothing but nitrous oxide at that point
is when shit starts popping off and
people,
people are.
People are walking around my apartment
who are never physically there.
I was seeing a bunch of shit.
Oh Dude,
like actual fucking people,
man.
I watched a dude walk through my
apartment and fucking pick up,
pick up my bong and take a hit and blow
out smoke at fucking then like put it
down.
And the dude walked through the wall.
He wasn't never fucking.
They're every looked as real as I did.
I had fucking like tactile
hallucinations.
I had fucked.
Could feel things big time dude.
Because here's like,
here's my whole thing.
And,
and
I kind of still believe this to this day
is,
you know,
that like our little,
our little,
a three dimensional experiences is very
small,
small part of what's going on in the
universe right there.
There's dimensions,
there's,
you know,
all frequencies,
everything and that like did,
if you do enough drugs like um,
the barriers between these different
compartments of the universe becoming
eroded somehow,
you know,
like I started hearing voices and,
and to an extent I fucking believe still
that that shit was real.
Like,
uh,
these spirits that we're fucking talking
to me.
I'm hearing the voices,
like I had a conversation with a friend
of mine sells weed about a very similar
thing where I was saying that I think
that something happens when the,
when you smoke pot,
it's not just that you get high,
but that the way you interface with the
world changes and then the world changes
because of that.
Not,
not the world changes the world changed
for you or for him,
but the world that I'm experiencing
different.
Yeah.
Like in the quantum physics kind of
sense.
I don't know.
I'm too stupid for that.
What I'm saying is that my feeling about
the world is that when you,
when you change the way your brain
works,
which is essentially what you're doing
to get really high,
he changed the way you think about the
world.
I think the world that you experience is
different.
Sure.
It's like,
you know,
like people think like this is a very
simplistic way of looking at it,
but it's sort of parallel.
You know,
some people think,
oh,
the world sucks.
Everything sucks and their life always
sucks,
and then there's people that are always
super positive and super happy and their
life is always happening.
There's something about when you get
like really high,
like especially marijuana because
marijuana is a sensitivity drug.
It's almost like the opposite of a lot
of drugs because a lot of drugs make you
insensitive.
Like alcohol makes you belonged,
right?
You,
you're not aware of people looking at
you,
you don't give a fuck.
You're like,
Whoa,
you get drunk,
you get her loud and you're crazier and
your social cues get skewed.
You don't see marijuana has the
opposite.
Marijuana.
You get like really aware of other
people.
People will call it paranoid because you
start thinking about all these
possibilities that you never thought of
before,
but I feel like the way you interface
with the world becomes very different.
You're aware of all these different
possibilities.
You start thinking about things that you
fucked up when you were in high school.
You know,
you start thinking of mushrooms are the
worst for that.
Oh yeah.
Oh sure.
Oh God,
I made a mistake.
It makes you accountable.
I get too introspective.
I mean I been forever,
but is it too introspective?
I got,
I got to house how to like just started
picking myself apart like a and you
know,
putting myself on trial in a sense right
now,
like just too introspective or I've just
determined that I just suck,
you know?
But maybe that's just a perspective.
Like I think the introspective aspect of
it,
one of the reasons why it comes up,
it feels like to me is because there's a
bunch of shit about yourself that you
don't like,
but you don't address.
So if it forces you,
hey,
in order to truly live in the moment,
you have to be balanced.
You have to be like,
I've looked at it at all and I don't
understand.
I made mistakes and here's where I'm at.
But if you've never looked at yourself,
if you never looked at those mistakes,
then you should have like this backlog
of shit you have to deal with.
And I agree with that.
I agree with that.
Except when it becomes just a morbid
fucking flogging of oneself,
right?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Which is,
which is what it would come to,
but I feel like that more flogging
yourself comes from you.
Like the,
the debt analogy is a good analogy
because if you're like massive debt and
you go to spend money,
you know,
because I don't even have any money,
how am I spending this money?
Whereas if you're even and you go to
spend the money,
you're like,
no big deal.
I'm just spending some money.
It's normal.
Right?
I think that when you don't have an
accounting of who you are and what
you've done and especially I think the
big one is your effect on other people,
you know,
that's the one that comes up with me on
mushrooms or on pot,
especially on edibles.
It's like how I've interacted with other
people and even if I thought it was
justified and maybe I was justified
when,
when it comes up on pot,
especially on edibles,
the big one for me at least,
that's where I feel like the most
accountable I'm gonna have to think
about like my behavior the most.
I always feel like with the edible
thing,
it always feels like,
could I have done better?
Instead of just being like,
was I okay?
Like,
yeah,
that guy was being a dick to you.
You have fuck him.
It's never that.
It's always like maybe I could have
caught on earlier to how he was feeling
and three assessed how I was
communicating with them and then instead
of being defensive or aggressive,
right.
I mean maybe I could've handled it
better.
Why?
Hey Man.
It sounds like you're working a great
spiritual program with your edibles.
I tried to do it all the time,
but when I'm with edibles,
like I said this before and people go,
oh no,
but I think pot makes you a better
person.
I really do because I think all that
responsibility and accountability pot.
But you know,
my partner to my boos,
bone bone is connected to.
Right?
You don't have to look.
You don't.
Honestly,
no one has to do anything.
I get as much high and as much.
Um,
mental clarity from yoga is I do
anything.
I really do dope.
I mean if someone told me I couldn't
smoke pot for the rest of my life,
but I could do yoga or I could just
smoke pot for the rest of my life and
not to yoga.
I think I would take the yoga.
Wow.
I really do because Yoga gives me,
um,
I mean,
I love the feeling of pot.
I really do.
But Yoga gives me,
um,
a relaxation when it's over,
like a,
there was a clarity that comes from
things that was like,
it's friendly after Blake Post Yoga
class,
those are like the,
that is the friendliest,
nicest group of fucking people go Stan,
you want to meet some Nice folks?
Stand outside of a yoga class window.
Yoga classes,
exiting.
You'll meet like the most balanced nice
people because they drained all the
bullshit of themselves.
He created pause so I can take a leak
already.
I'm going,
we're not,
we're not pausing though.
He's such a good guy.
He really is.
He's such a good guy and he's always
like worried that he's not a good guy.
And he's always like,
you know,
like coming down on himself and we'll
talk about this a little bit.
Um,
Al Madrigal,
I'll set this up so he doesn't have to.
So he doesn't have to be uncomfortable.
Allah magical.
When he was here was talking about he,
he gets mad at guys like Steevo because
Steevo is a guy who kinda came to stand
up after he did other things.
And now it's like I don't want the thing
that is like what I feel is my chosen
thing in life,
the most amazing thing in life to me to
be something that someone comes to as a
last resort.
But I'll even thinks it's stupid that he
thinks like that.
And then so like when he said I like
Steve,
I was Kinda bumped down.
So Steve Texted me about it and Steve
and I talked and I told we were supposed
to do a podcast anyway.
So it was like this question of whether
or not we should talk about it like when
it came to the actual show itself.
But my feeling on all that stuff is that
it's whoever does stand up just stand
up.
Like it's bullshit.
I was just explaining that you're a
great guy and the whole al magical thing
without you having to be in the room and
feel uncomfortable.
But I think that anybody like that
judgment thing of like,
this is not a stand up.
You're not a standup.
He's not a standing.
Right.
So insecure.
It's so crazy.
Especially when your premise is that you
care so much about standard.
Yeah.
Well,
I love what you said to me at the comedy
store the other night.
He said,
well,
I just love standup.
So like I want more.
I want there to be Martin.
Yeah.
I want more people doing standup.
I love it.
I love,
I love.
I love funny shit.
Yeah.
If you're doing standup and people were
laughing that stand up.
It doesn't.
I don't care if you're a fucking
surgeon,
you know,
if you're a brain surgeon and he decided
to stand up at night,
are you not a standup?
Like once you do stand up comedy to me,
you go onstage,
you tell some jokes,
people laugh.
You're a fucking comic.
You know?
I mean,
I don't care if it's an open mic night.
You're a comic.
Sure.
He might not be a professional stand up
comedian.
Right?
But if you,
if someone says,
oh,
I'm a comic too,
like,
okay,
it doesn't mean you're good.
Like,
you know,
like you could,
you could be be a guy who works on cars,
but you just fuck up constantly.
It doesn't make you a professional
mechanic,
you know what I'm saying?
Right.
It's like once you.
You're doing it.
We're all doing the same thing.
Thinking suck one dick.
You're a cock sucker.
You might not be good at it.
Let me tell you about the way that guy
sucks.
Good taste.
Terrible at it.
I get my dick sucked by a guy one time.
I was totally underwhelmed.
Yeah.
Why did that happen?
Was It on purpose?
It started out like I'm a joke now.
It wasn't a joke.
It,
this,
this happened in December of 2002.
And uh,
I was,
I was doing a show at the 9:30 club in
d,
c after the show.
There was great blah,
blah,
great place,
fucking waste.
And I was really wasted and I had this
shady manager and he was really wasted
too.
And he was talking to this person who
appeared to be a hot chick,
right.
Appeared to be a hot chick.
And I was like.
And so I kind of started talking to this
person who appeared to be a hot chick
and,
and rude to the person away from the
shady manager.
And I was feeling really good about it,
you know,
turns out in hindsight that had written,
had we not been so intoxicated it was
rather evidence,
but we were really intoxicated.
So we're walking away from the,
from the 9:30 club,
um,
if that was that of safari or 9:31 of
the two,
but I don't think they have safari
anymore.
But walking down the street,
going to the next place.
Someone pulls me aside with a,
you know,
a friend pulls me aside and says,
Hey,
just why,
you know that,
that person you're talking to.
Um,
was it like a,
not a girl or.
But it wasn't like I would say,
uh,
that that person is a road map for a
diet was what the was described as
hermaphrodite.
Meaning I get,
you know,
they'd be like,
of both in both women.
And um,
and uh,
they did describe that the person had
had a surgical operation to remove the
male parts.
So it was kind of a chick,
right?
And I was just like,
oh,
whatever,
I don't care,
you know,
I was just like,
oh,
whatever,
you know,
wound up.
I wrote about this in my book.
I'm like,
I really had the sense,
you know,
I,
I came back to the hotel and,
and um,
and uh,
the,
the sense that I got and this is pretty
fucking outrageous and take on it was
that,
here's this person who was,
um,
kind of,
I dunno,
damages and mean word,
but like,
you know,
there was something or other,
this person wanted to be loved,
wanting to be accepted.
Now there was something more,
there was some kind of thing.
And I wanted this person to feel,
you know,
and that was kind of where the,
I think that was part of what was going
on.
You know,
I was like,
Hey,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna play ball with this person and
we're going to snuggle all night.
And so like,
uh,
so then,
and that was in the hole in the course
of the evening,
there was,
there was oral sex and um,
a while later,
this is where it gets really crazy.
I wasn't doing that.
And it's the show.
Dr Drew's loved line shown and talked to
Dr Drew,
Dr. Drew says,
uh,
you know,
I'm paraphrasing,
he says,
Steve,
oh,
there's no such thing as a
hermaphrodite.
What happened was a dude,
suck your Dick.
Wait a minute.
There's no such thing as Dr. drew told
me,
uh,
I don't think that's true.
Well,
you know,
and I'm not a doctor,
so I probably shouldn't say that she's
wrong about pot and he's not a potsom
smoker.
Dr Chu was,
I love Dr. Jew almost more than anybody,
but they bet the first chink in his
armor happened when,
uh,
when I asked him Dr drew,
why,
why is,
uh,
is jerking off so much more pleasurable
if you tickle your balls while you're
doing it.
And he said,
I didn't know that was the case.
What's think jerks off with his head out
the window.
I was like,
how do you thought you knew everything?
What feel good?
It feels good to touch your balls.
Same Way.
The reason why it feels good for other
people to touch your balls,
like listen,
Rub your own neck.
It feels good to rub your own name.
Just like it feels good to get a
massage,
right?
Jesus Christ.
Of course.
It feels good to rub your balls with
dumb answer,
but since you brought up the magic
bullet per maphrodite find out.
That's true.
I need to know because I'm pretty sure
that it's rare,
but it does exist that there have been
people that have been born.
I androgynous,
I think is,
is it androgynous?
Has something.
But uh,
he says hermaphrodite does not exist and
well that doesn't seem to.
He maybe he's just fucking around with
you and that doesn't seem to make sense
though because I've talked to because
that's a medical term.
I've talked to him about it on many
occasions,
but he,
I liked Dr drew,
I don't want to.
I want to shit on Dr. Joe's was a good
guy,
but he fucked up.
He fucked up when he started talking
about Hillary Clinton's medical
condition on the right and they fired
him from CNN for it and now do that.
Right?
You can't do that.
You're not.
If you're a doctor and you started
talking about someone's medical
condition without actually appraising
them physically,
you don't see that in the tabloid
magazine.
This doctor commented,
but then they have to clarify that this
doctor,
like the person they're talking about
wasn't never one of their patients.
She made an assessment about her health.
Right,
and that's dangerous because you're
doing it on television.
You're talking about someone who's
running for president.
Meanwhile,
look,
he's right in some ways like she blacked
out,
hit her head,
had brain trauma that Bill Clinton
talked about publicly.
Bill Clinton talked about how she was in
recovery for six months from brain
trauma,
from having a seizure falling down and
smashing her head off the ground when
you're 67 years old or however old she
was when that happened.
That's really dangerous.
Like I know a lot about head trauma.
I've.
I've researched a lot about head trauma.
I've experienced a bunch of myself,
as I'm sure you have.
I know you did from Tim Kennedy special.
I talked to you about it afterwards.
I'm like,
I can't let somebody do that to you.
I know.
I asked her to drop me on my head and he
dropped me.
He lifted me up by my neck,
choking me out with my feet off the
ground,
and then it let you go,
drop me,
dropped you on your head.
That's so bad for announced like a
basset died.
For sure.
People die from metal and to my soft.
Oh my God.
What's the super,
just super dangerous.
Like anytime you fall you hit your head.
This is how you have to think about and
do that again.
Please don't,
don't think of it as hitting your head.
Think of that as you getting hit by the
world.
That's what it's like.
The whole world is like slamming into
your fucking head.
And I was talking to Tony Hawk about the
cte stuff so bad.
He said that,
uh,
that if you have a gene
predisposes to Alzheimer's,
then your brain doesn't regenerate or
he'll,
you know.
And um,
and so,
so,
so you're more,
you're more at risk for cte if that's
the case,
if you had that gene give you don't have
the gene,
then you're better off and you said,
so I've went.
So I went and got it.
I went and got this test and it
determined that I don't have the Jane.
So I was like,
okay,
cool.
And I thought about it for awhile and
then I had to text him like,
Hey,
so what were you going
do if it turned out that you did have
the gene?
And he's like,
oh,
I didn't have a plan.
So then I asked myself do I want to go
get that test?
Because what happens?
It turns out that you do have the gene
and there's nothing to do about it.
You're super bummed out about it.
Bombed.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's ways you can,
I guess you could probably mitigate the
onset of Alzheimer's now.
I would have to like look at what
they're doing now and what we can figure
out and they're working hard at it.
But yeah man,
it's fucking on that shit.
I mean the really you need medical
science to figure out like they have to
figure out.
I mean there has to be some pretty
legitimate studies and those studies
take a long time because you have to
follow people with Alzheimer's.
You gotta to try one way with one group
and another way with another group and
see like what the,
you know,
which group has more progress.
But the bottom line is anytime you're
getting hit in the head,
it's fucking bad.
Tennis players get,
get concussions,
you know,
like people get concussions from playing
soccer,
you know,
who gets brain trauma because it gets
really crazy.
People ride jet skis,
the bouncing of jet skis.
It shakes your fucking brain inside your
head.
I'm
thinking of times when I got hit in the
head hard enough that I actually lost
time,
you know,
where like a time traveled because I
blacked out,
right?
Like um,
I got in the ring with a,
the fucking,
the Monday night raw.
The wrestling was so fucking terrible.
It was so bad because here's the thing,
I was never fucking wrestling fan.
I never got into.
I just didn't understand it.
And,
and um,
and so like when we got in the fucking
rang to promote it,
like we kind of walked through what the
moves we're going to be,
you know,
with this restaurant who's since passed
away,
his name is [inaudible] Maga is fucking
jacked guy.
They the column,
the Samoan bulldozer.
And uh,
so we walk through what it was and like
I'm going to do a back flip off the top
rope and he was going to do this and
we'd been knocked over,
you know,
and it's pretty incredible how they just
very loosely like walk through every
horse,
very loosely choreographed.
But we know that the moves are and we
know it's supposed to be the final move.
What I did not know,
and this was this period we have really
bad,
is that I did not know that the match is
not fucking over until you actually play
dead.
You have to be like completely still at
the end when he was supposed to,
uh,
there was some fucking pretty major hit
like 10 to my head or to check whatever
it was.
I can't remember.
But the final hit like in,
in,
in when we're doing it live,
it was,
he was getting so much fucking harder.
Oh yeah.
I know what it was.
He jumped off the top rope on and,
and,
and fuck landed.
I landed on me.
Yeah.
He jumped off the top rope and landed on
the size of that flat.
Oh No.
Now here's the thing that's supposed to
be over.
But if you notice I'm fucking not
playing dead.
I'm rolling around like I see I'm moving
around,
moving around.
So here,
here he notices it supposed to be over.
At this point he's offended because he's
like,
I'm not now.
This is not.
This is never supposed to look at this
elbow.
Boom.
That knocked me out and I don't remember
anything after that.
So you don't.
I'm begging him.
I'm praying them.
But the thing is that I'm still throwing
his world.
It's not over until you play dead.
But I didn't know that they didn't even
show the end.
They never say just cut away from it
because it got so ugly and I don't
remember leaving the ring.
And then on top of that I went home and
fucking destroyed my brain some more
with the Goddamn nitris out.
You know,
you talked to him afterwards to Jamie,
why don't you fucking crack me in?
She was cool with me.
I went back,
I went back to a and worked my way in.
I was like with my video camera trying
to get him to fucking choke me
unconscious.
Like,
like Tim Kennedy did know I wanted to
film that for a thing and he was totally
down.
But then like they got hip to what I was
doing.
They're like,
and all the wwe Bras I kinda came and
gotten kicked out.
He was cool with me.
But,
but yeah,
that that's offensive to a wrestler to
get in there and play in their world and
not like.
Because when I,
when I get hit really hard,
like to me like I react,
I laughed,
you know,
like whatever.
Like it's a thing and I,
you know,
like I'm reacting to it and that was
offensive to him.
It has to be final and us be over that
elbow to the head was the fucking or can
imagine that was giant dude.
Yeah.
After what happened and how did he pass
away?
I think he had a heart attack.
He'd be bad.
Yeah.
That guy was great.
I got a lot of those um,
wrestlers they get hooked on pills
because they're in prime time.
It's a big problem with pro wrestling.
Wrestling is one of the most
unappreciated or under appreciated
things in terms of like how difficult it
is for the performers was one of the
most difficult jobs a person could do.
Those guys are on tour hundreds of days
a year,
if not 300 days a year.
Right.
They're constantly on the road and
they're doing that all the time.
They're slamming into each other,
throwing each other on the ground,
pile driving each other,
slamming,
jumping from the top rope.
I get it,
man.
Massive,
massive trauma.
Those
guys all suffer from some kind of trauma
for sure.
Yeah.
That was a heavy blackout.
And um,
I,
I can think of a few times where I just
blacked out because I hit my head so
hard and then there's other times where
I hit my head and then starting the
nausea kicks in and start barfing.
That happened when I was 10 years old.
Well,
you probably got a lot of brain damage,
bro.
Yeah.
And what's fucked up about is that it
doesn't affect me now,
but that's just creeping up on me for
later.
Well,
it definitely affects me now.
It's just like,
how much does it affect you?
It's like you ever wake up,
I'm sure you've broken up,
hung over,
and you're like,
Oh God,
I feel like Shit.
Well that's how you feel because what
you did to your body,
but if that's how you felt every day,
you would just get used to that.
That's,
that would be who you are.
And when you fuck your brain up with.
The weird thing is you never go back to
how you used to feel.
It's not like you can hit a switch and
you go,
how was I when I was 18?
And I had never been hitting the head,
let me hit this switch,
Click,
oh,
so much clarity that that's not
available.
So you just deal with how you are,
like you ever wake up in the morning and
you just feel kind of stupid.
You can't forget where your keys are.
What am I supposed to do today?
You just feel dull.
Everybody's been there,
right?
Because field,
dull.
Maybe she'll jet lagged like,
you know,
jet lag.
I just kept saying I feel tired.
I'm always fucking tired right now.
That just in general because um,
and,
and I wonder if that's it because that
was a factor for sure.
I got on the Vegan Diet,
right?
And I remember a while,
a while until I started feeling fucking
tired and I,
it's like,
man,
it's got to be my fucking Vegan Diet and
pissed,
you know?
And then there was a point where I said,
fuck the Vegan Diet,
I'm going to eat fish again and eggs,
but it's still tired and I was still
fucking ever get your blood work done.
Um,
I should,
I do.
I mean,
I get,
I get like full panel everything you do.
I mean as far as like for like stds and
shit,
I'm like,
no,
you right,
you should go to a doctor that can check
out your nutritional profile and they
might do that.
Yeah.
They might say you're deficient on iron.
It could be like a nice to have that,
like that.
Tell me that my testosterone is low.
My vitamin D,
a lot of that also comes from brain
damage.
Oh yeah.
Testosterone being low as a bigger issue
with football players,
fighters.
Um,
your pituitary gland is very sensitive
and that's one of the things that
happens with people literally just from
jet skiing.
Like I was saying,
skiing in general,
like jumping ski jumps and stuff like
that.
Even without even get get getting hit in
the head,
which is anything that causes your head
to shake around a lot.
Like I'm sure headbanging like ACDC and
say I went to the fucking Chiropractor,
I've been to chiropractors and you know,
I'll go to the chiropractor and they're
familiar with Jack Ass and shit.
I've done and,
and yeah,
they'll like take my uh,
my x ray to look at my,
at my spine and they're like,
dude,
I don't understand it.
Like you're like fucking Keith Richards,
you know,
like there's,
there's like getting much,
much better shape than I expected you
would be in,
except for in my neck where I've got
the,
what do they call it,
the cad callous or are not callous.
The,
I don't know,
some kind of fucking build up.
Um,
and then calcium deposits or.
Oh,
Jesus,
he gets her head banging.
Yeah.
Some kind of.
So you have some disc degeneration,
some sort of deterioration.
Yeah.
Anyway,
whatever it is,
it's my neck is more fucked up than
anything.
And so then there's more of that super
skeptical of chiropractors.
By the way,
I'm not a big fan either.
I just heard too many regular doctors.
So that's just horse shit,
right.
I went to a,
it got to a point where I was like,
fuck,
you know,
and,
and I was doing some job,
um,
I was getting ready to do some job and
you know,
you go to this side physician,
he'd say,
clear to you before you can be on,
like of work a TV or a movie job.
Go to this fucking physician to the
stars who just did their own and she's
shining a light down my throat.
And she says,
hmm.
Um,
the,
the opening at the back of your throat
is very narrow diy,
like,
do you ever find that you sleep a full
night sleep,
but you wake up and you're still tired?
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
that's exactly fucking me.
You know,
I'll sleep for eight hours,
nine hours.
I get up fucking tired.
Sleep apnea.
Yeah.
So she said,
I recommend you get a sleep study.
Did you do it?
I did.
I got to say,
they said I have a mild to moderate
sleep apnea.
Super Common.
You know,
you get a mouthpiece to fix that.
I,
now I got to you,
but I already have a mouthpiece.
Fortunately for you,
it fits on the bottom,
on the bottom,
and what it does is as a tongue
depressor and it presses down your
tongue,
the tongue from sliding back.
I'd right here.
I have a buddy of mine that,
that fixed everything.
I know God does it to.
I have to do that immediately.
It's,
um,
there's a doctor in Encino,
Dr Kirby and who was famous for it.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's super common like sleep apnea,
people with big tongues.
Your tongue as you laid back,
especially if you lay on your back,
it falls back and covers over your air
hole.
Right.
That's what causes a lot of gagging and
loud snoring,
you know.
But it's a huge issue for people.
And that's c pap machine,
man mean.
Some people need to have it.
Me,
I did,
I tried it,
I tried,
I tried it for awhile and I was able to
fall asleep.
But then about an hour or two into it,
the fuck,
they just blowing,
blowing me away and wakes me up and
there's.
And there's,
I couldn't fucking do.
It's too weird.
You're sleeping with darth vader mascot
is.
It's too weird for really fat people
though.
It's huge and the extent that you have
to clean that fucking thing.
And speaking of family pieces,
easy.
What do we go from there though?
We,
we started out with some sort of
reporting we would.
We're talking about Al Madrigal and then
we got on dudes sucking dude's Dick.
Then we got
onto the head drama.
We have an important thing to say about
head trauma.
Like what did we start off?
It was just that it's Kinda bad to,
you know,
being tired.
Yeah.
If,
I mean guarantee you that has something
to do with why your testosterone is low.
Also,
you know,
another thing that has to do with how
many like healthy fats,
how much healthy fat in your diet,
because fats and even cholesterol are
literally the precursors for hormones.
It's like how your body,
like one of the things that people find
when they go on a heavy fat based diet,
like a key to genic diet is,
um,
they are hormones.
Jump Up.
It's because your body,
that's how your body makes hormones.
Your body uses fats and cholesterol
actually to make hormones.
Now when you say healthy fats like
Avocados,
coconut oil,
avocado is interesting because it's a
combination of a saturated fat and
uncheck trade fat and most people assume
that saturated fat is bad for you,
but it's not.
A lot of that came out of the sugar
industry that you're.
Your fucking dad was probably a part of
the sugar industry paid off and this was
from the New York Times and a bunch of
like really reputable newspapers
reported on this.
Really recently.
The sugar industry paid off scientists
to lie about the effects of saturated
fats to cover up the effects of sugar.
It's really sad because so many people
to this day running around worrying
about saturated fat and not worrying
about sugar because they're worried
about saturated fat in their diet and
that's what made people switch over to
shit like margarine,
which are terrible for you.
Didn't even recommend margin anymore.
That's how trans fats get introduced
into people's terrible.
They're trying to make them illegal and
they've made them illegal in America,
but they still have like another year or
so where you're allowed to sell it,
which is hilarious.
They give these companies an extra year
or two to get rid of all the bullshit
that they,
they,
they made so that they can still fuck
people over for 12 months and make
money.
They knew that that stuff was bad for
you decades ago and they just,
they've been like la La,
La,
not listening.
Damn.
Diane didn't tell you this story about,
uh,
about my dad Kay.
So when I was 12 I moved to Toronto,
right.
Living in Canada.
Dad was the president of Nabisco,
Canada and I was,
speaking of head,
I was a fucking rabid motley crue fan.
Right?
I fucking loved Motley crew.
This was 1987.
Shout of the right now this is that are
girls,
girls tour,
right?
I mean I got fucking Motley crue all
over my bedroom walls and fucking crazy
about these fucking guys.
Now they come to uh,
to Toronto for their girls,
girls,
girls tour.
They're doing maple leaf gardens and I,
the day before the concert,
well I should say my dad knew that would
a big fan.
I wasn't the Bisco Canada had a sky box
in the arena,
but my dad also knew that,
that nobody from Nabisco gave a fuck
about a motley crue concerts.
The skybox was going to be empty.
So my dad,
my dad said to me,
he said,
had no,
I'm and she loved Motley crue and so I'm
going to bring you to the concert.
We can sit in the Dubiski skybox and I'd
tell my dad,
dad watching Motley crue through a
plate,
glass window sucks.
And he says,
and he says,
all right,
well,
you know,
basically fuck you,
he's like,
if you can do better and then we'll do
better with then we'll use your tickets
if you can,
you know,
fucking.
I was 13,
you know,
so the day before the concert I see on
the news,
they're like complaining.
They're like,
these fucking asshole rockstars come to
our city and fucking fuck around like
one way or another.
And I'm like,
dude,
they're here.
The fucking molly quit.
What would he say?
Rockstar?
They made the news for something like
blush.
I forget what it was.
I think they started some kind of fire,
it's something created,
but they were on the news and the like,
they were complaining to these fucking
guys come here and so I'm like,
they're in Toronto,
they're in the city now and the fucking
concert tomorrow.
So I deduce that they're in a hotel and
I'm going to fucking find these guys.
I want to fuck.
I was 13 and so I go fucking running to
my room.
Right.
Like right away I'm thinking I know all
the guys and I know their real names
like Vince Neil is Vincent Wharton,
right.
Like I know all their names and I'm
like,
I couldn't fucking check into the hotel
as Frank Carlton Ferranto right.
That's Nikki Sixx.
They're not going to use their real
names.
And I was like,
they're going to check into the hotel
under the name of their manager.
Right.
And then I guess just go right into my
room and I fucking check on my little
cassette fucking album sleeves and check
everyone.
It says doc mcgee,
which was their manager at Doc Mcgee.
So I'm like,
that's the fucking one I go run into.
Uh,
the,
the phone book and the fucking opening
up the hotel,
like the yellow pages and I districts
are calling every fucking hotel in the
yellow pages and when the hotel answers
and like,
will you please put me through to Mr
Mcgee's room right in the fucking show
was like a Sunday instead of Saturday.
And my dad's like watching college
football,
right.
I'm sitting on the phone call and every
fucking hotel in Toronto who's going
down the list,
not even calling the ones with the ads,
like literally just sticking to the list
so I don't miss one.
And my mom's pissed because there was no
call waiting.
She's like,
you're tying up the house phone.
My Dad,
all my dad ever wanted was for me to
show initiative and to be like,
motivated for something,
you know.
And so my dad's like super still,
I'm on fire.
I'm telling my mom,
mom called Motley crue fucking and my
dad,
my calls off my mom,
you know,
like honey,
like let him do his thing.
And I fucking sat there for probably two
or three hours.
There's calling hotels and get.
They put me through to this room.
There was one like false alarm,
you know,
but then the second nicky's room that I
got through to the guy picks up the
phone and I said,
hello,
is that Dr Mcgee?
And he says,
no,
this is [inaudible] brother Scott.
He's and I'm like,
as in Motley crue.
And he says,
uh,
he says,
how did you get this number?
And I told him,
I fuck,
I just call it every fucking hotel in
the yellow painted.
I just told them,
I said,
I just called every hotel in the yellow
pages.
Is the crew there?
And,
and,
and he goes,
he goes,
Whoa,
wait,
hold on a second.
Are you fucking kidding me?
That's awesome.
And he says,
uh,
he goes,
I'm so impressed by what you did.
And he says,
he says,
how would you like it if I put you on
the list for backstage passes and I can,
I can give you tickets in the fifth
road.
So he gave me two tickets in the fifth
row.
Fucking backstage passes.
My Dad and my went fucking show for my
dad's a chauffeur to the fucking maple
leaf gardens.
We've gotten the fucking press lined
with the FEC.
Fifth row,
fifth row.
It's insane.
That's actually better than the first
row.
You're like a back on.
It was the dope because I was fucking
head bay like a magic kit myself.
Hell of brain damage that he did like a.
How are you not showing me with fucking
Nikki Sixx and Tommy Lee's picture?
No,
no,
no.
But Google.
Steven fucking Steve and Motley crue
man.
When you were 13.
I was fucking 13.
We went up to the sky box and I put my,
my,
my ghetto blaster.
Fuck.
I put my ghetto blaster next to the
little speaker deal and there's me and
Tommy Lee.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
And then uh,
and seeing how old is Tommy Lee?
I got,
that's crazy.
Me and Nikki sixx right there.
You're like a bb.
I was a fucking baby dude.
That is so weird.
Yeah.
And you know,
I'm standing next to these guys and I'm
like,
I don't have fucking,
you know,
like shit to talk to them about,
but the fact that I was standing next to
those guys and I was like,
you know what,
I'm here backstage with my fucking
heroes and it's because I fucking
decided so you know,
like there's something about that that
gave me this,
this,
this and mentality.
And they see,
look,
top left right there,
check it out.
Fucking all these years later when they,
when they announced that they're back
together and going on their carnival of
sins tour,
Tommy Lee asked me to do something
fucked up and introduce them.
Dude.
How full circle.
Wow.
That's crazy data was the dopest as the
dude on the far right.
That's mcmorris with the hat.
Yeah.
He's got like a generative bone disease.
What's going on with them?
Yeah.
Like,
I forget what it's called,
but uh,
yeah,
he's like,
they got to like have them come out when
the lights aren't on leg,
you know,
or I don't know,
maybe he's doing better at it.
Limps gay.
He's in rough shape.
Brianna,
I love that story,
man,
and my dad,
you know,
it was like my kind of how my dad is.
That's awesome man.
Yeah,
dude,
it's a great story.
Well,
thank you man.
It made,
it really made me into a monster in some
regard because I think that at that
young age it's like,
you know,
I really can fucking,
if you just.
And I've always said,
it doesn't matter what people want,
it just mattered how bad they really put
them on.
And I mean,
of course they definitely matters what
they want.
You want to play basketball against,
of course within some.
But I want it right,
of course,
within,
within some parameters of reality.
But,
but a factor,
what do they say they say that,
uh,
that uh,
luck is when preparation meets
opportunity.
Yes.
Which is dope.
I love her.
I love that fucking saying.
Yeah,
there's a lot of variables and you can
control some of them.
Right.
And you definitely saw some of them,
like with like with fucking standup and
at a really wanted,
he brought up our magic.
I'm all,
I'm going to say this quickly,
I don't want to be careful not to lynch
the guy because you know,
I'd like a dyke.
I don't want everyone's at all.
Fuck that guy from,
from everything.
I understand.
He's hilarious and great guy.
He's a great guy.
He's hilarious.
And you should absolutely check out as
comedy special on the show time,
which is called shrimping.
Ain't easy to decide for yourself.
Is this guy fucking funny?
Yes.
He's very,
very funny.
He's very funny.
Not ever met the guy.
I didn't know shit about him but.
But um,
and this was,
this was a,
was it 2012 or 2000?
13.
I had been headline in comedy clubs
since 2010.
You know,
I had got into it and I've been doing
standup for seven years now.
Yeah,
well technically it's been,
it's been almost 11 years since the
first time I ever tried it,
which was a,
at the laugh factory when skyler stone
in 2006 asked me to do a stunt at the,
at the laugh factory because he was
hosting a show and he wants to,
you know,
so I'm like,
yeah,
I'll do a fucking stunt,
like whatever.
And I showed up.
I had no game plan when I walked in.
Just as I said,
I said I can't,
there's nothing fucking crazier than me
getting on stage trying to make people
laugh.
That's the stuff that was,
I was terrified.
So I tried it that night,
but I never got like really hardcore
like in earnest and so 2000 who'd
started 2010 now 2012,
2013 amount of point where I'm super
comfortable in my,
in my 45 minutes,
right.
Like my whatever my hour is at that
point.
My like I'm just really comfortable in
it and I'm starting to feel like stale
because I'm fucking going through the
motions and the shit.
Like,
uh,
you know what that's like writing,
you get to a point where you're just
like fucking with dying because I'm not
doing anything new,
not doing anything new.
And,
and,
uh,
and the worst is if is,
if you'd go back to a fucking place and
do the same material,
that's the,
you know,
and I don't,
I don't ever want to fucking do that.
I,
so,
so I'm like a kid,
uh,
my comfort zone and I got to get out of
it,
but I ended up at,
but I just wasn't doing it.
As I finally put my,
put my foot down,
I said,
fuck it.
Okay,
this is what I'm doing.
I'm promising myself,
I'm going to go do 10 minutes,
10 minute set here in La and,
and even if I have to,
I put it on my calendar for one week
later and even if I have to bomb,
I'm not backing out period.
I'm going,
I'm doing 10,
20 minutes.
And I wrote fucking 10.
I wrote a fucking set and I went over to
the laugh factory and I did it and I was
thrilled.
I got some laughs,
you know,
then I go over to the fucking the Improv
and I'm like,
Hey,
you know,
and I made the mistake,
it was a mistake where I say,
Hey,
I'm working on some new material.
You never say that when you're on new
material to the audience.
Right.
But,
but I mentioned it.
Say Hey,
or maybe I did it and then I said,
hey guys,
thanks.
You know that like I was trying some new
material and then thanks for,
you know,
and I diligently recorded the fucking
set to play it back.
And here were the last word,
you know,
like I wrote my own shit.
I went there and I fucking did,
didn't do shit and I worked it out and I
recorded it and you know,
that's how you do it.
Well,
when I get off the stage and I'm
thrilled because of fucking people left,
you know,
and I sit in the crowd,
I sit in the crowd,
the host brings up the next comment,
next comic is Allah magical.
He walks out and he goes,
oh my God,
what did we just see?
We just saw steevo working on new
material.
I just,
and he's just like,
I just can't take it anymore.
Like I just,
I just can't believe that,
you know,
that,
this thing that,
that I consider my calling in life,
standup comedy that I care about it so
much.
And now we have Steve and Dustin diamond
out here doing this thing.
It's like,
I can't believe that these people are
taking something that's so sacred to me
and just using it as their last resort.
And I'm sitting right there watching him
say this shit.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
Like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Dude?
It was just an odd.
There was a blatant attack from the
stage,
you know?
And I'm like,
I'm like,
it's not fucking right because a
motherfuckers were laughing,
you know,
I played it back and be like,
I got in the car right after that,
you know why we're.
And I sat there,
I couldn't even believe it.
And then there's,
there was a lady that was talking at our
table and he just went in on her like
beyond,
beyond what was like,
what was like,
Hey,
be quiet,
you know,
start with starting in with like the
personal,
like whatever.
And I don't even care.
But what I perceived was that here's a
guy who's claiming that his whole
passionate standup comedy,
but his whole attack on me and then
berating the woman.
There weren't any jokes,
you know,
like it was almost like he just four
went the act of performing comedy to
kind of be mean to me because he was
upset that you were doing standup.
He's upset that I was doing standup and,
and,
and whatever.
But then then after his set and he went
in and started selling drugs after that.
But after his set,
he comes over to the booth and I'm
sitting right next to the sound booth,
said right next to it.
And he comes over and says something to
the sound guy and kind of awkwardly
notices I'm sitting right there.
And then he comes over and leans over
the table and he says,
just so you know,
what you're doing isn't taken lately,
like face to face.
I felt like he totally insulted me just
so you know,
what you're doing isn't taken lightly.
Like I don't even know what it meant,
but I bet it was clear that the,
that the sentiment was like.
And I meant everything.
I said,
you know,
I felt like he came in and assaulted me
to my face on top of that and I was
just,
I was pretty bent out of shape about it,
but I didn't like say anything or,
you know,
and I certainly wouldn't have come here
to talk about that like at all except
what was it?
I was on here a couple weeks ago and
like I,
I see in my twitter feed my,
like my name is tagged and it says
listen to the podcast Douche.
And I'm like,
Huh.
And I'm like okay.
So.
So Al was on the Joe Rogan podcast and I
guess he's telling me to listen to it.
And then there was more like Brendan
Schaub replied and they're all playing
nice and I just plugged.
So I started listening to the album
magical thing and he's,
and he like ran out of the gate.
He's saying like,
Oh man,
I have this habit where I like kind of
create problems.
I just said I'd talk shit on people and
I create beefs and it's really
counterproductive and I should work on
it and I'd,
you know,
like it's not a good thing.
And he basically went onto apologized to
everybody under the sun,
you know,
like,
and then my name comes up and he makes
the distinction that,
oh,
well I actually don't feel bad about
fucking talking shit on Steve.
I don't feel.
He says I actually don't feel bad about
this at all.
And then he goes on to repeat like all
the shit that he said from the stage and
like,
I got so bad I'd fucking shade that
night,
you know,
your side texting.
We talked and,
and whatever.
Like he's just getting.
You made the great point.
He said,
hey,
you know,
he just,
he does that shit sometimes.
He says dumb shit and,
and,
uh,
and I actually had a conversation with
them about it and it was a hilarious
conversation because he was like,
he calls me up and I answered the phone.
He was like,
how you doing?
I'm like,
well,
not that fucking good,
you know?
I was so fucking pissed.
I didn't even really fucking sleep last
night.
You know,
when I was,
I was really kept you up.
It kept me up.
Dude.
That's crazy.
How do you live with the people affected
that much?
That's a great question.
It's a really meditative.
It'll,
I haven't got into the 10 and I've been
doing it very fucking little.
I got to do it way more.
You can't let someone rent space in your
head like that.
I know he said was very mild.
It was,
it was.
And we sit on the podcast.
He was also kind of conciliatory.
He was like,
no,
military to everybody but me.
That's what I think what bothered me so
much.
He goes,
he goes,
I feel bad at doing this.
He goes,
but then,
but then when it comes to this depot,
oh,
I actually don't feel bad about this
one.
It's so stupid.
What you do is funny.
I've seen you.
I've seen you do stand up.
You're funny.
Well,
thank you man.
I appreciate it.
I in my mind,
hey,
I appreciate that so much and I think
that what,
what particularly fucking got me hot
about that was that the time that he
chose to attack me was when I had
fucking,
when I was really working the craft of
fucking call me writing my own material,
going out there,
getting outside of my comfort zone,
doing fucking new shit,
diligently recording it,
fucking like fucking craft.
And it was just a fucking shitty time.
So he really does care about standup
comedy.
But I think because of that carrying it,
it sometimes it blinds you,
you know,
and I'm very sensitive to it because I
experienced it a lot when I was first
starting out where people didn't think
that I fit into the mold of what they
thought.
A standup which should be sure that you
make that point because yeah,
it was fucking miles at the fact that I
got out of shape.
The way I did was bullshit.
Such a public figure two and your,
your,
your career has been so controversial.
That's why I don't understand why you're
so sensitive to criticism because you,
you've done everything you've done has
been chaos.
You know,
you've done so much chaos.
I mean,
I've just sort of imagined that so many
people.
Shit on you.
I guess I just,
I dunno,
I just think I fucking care about
comedy.
I would imagine him saying that to you
in person just so you know.
What you're doing is not taken lightly.
I would probably smack him.
I really have to have a really hard time
with that.
Like what doing standup would.
That's not taken lightly.
What you own.
Standup you out of your fucking mind.
Do you don't like it.
This is what I said to you the other
day.
Don't you like stand up?
If I,
I like standup.
I want my fucking mailman to try it.
He might be funny too.
One of the funniest guys I've ever
fucking met was a private detective that
I worked for.
He lost his license at a Dui and a I
want to be in his driver and I,
he needed a drive.
He needed an assistant in quotes,
but really what he needed as a guy to
drive him around because he lost his
license for six months or something like
that.
So I worked for them for like six
months.
I drove my,
he was the funniest fucking guy I ever
met in my life and while I was doing
standup,
I think I was 21 at the time and I think
he was probably 35,
36.
I was like,
this guy just did stand up.
He would fucking put me out of business.
That's all I could think of is like if
this guy went into stand up,
you know.
Meanwhile he was a man.
He had experienced life.
I was a boy.
Right.
But everybody that you like that wants
to do standup,
you should encourage them to do it.
Like my friend Brendan Schaub,
he does stand up and he faces the same
shit.
People like this fucking guy who's doing
standup.
I heard about similar,
very Sarah and shit on him,
but I.
But Eric was just being funny and I said
to him,
I go,
of course they're going to shit on you.
You're a big handsome gorilla.
Shockingly good luck.
Good looking fella.
And he's a great dude.
He's a great guy and he's funny.
He's fucking funny.
And I told him,
you should do stand up smart.
He's very smart.
He works hard.
He's been doing standup a year and he's
killing it.
He does.
He does really well.
I mean,
I saw him the other night at the comedy
store sandwiched in between me and
sharks swimming with sharks.
He was doing a real show,
like at a real show and he had a real
good set.
Dane Cook helped me a lot.
Man.
I know he's a polarizing figure,
but when I,
when I first,
uh,
when I got into standup and earnest,
because back in 2006,
I was like,
man,
I should,
I really liked this.
You know,
I tried it,
I got on stage for a few minutes that
first night and people have.
The sense I got was that people were
excited to see me.
They were rooting for me.
They wanted me to do well
for some reason,
like,
like a,
I can be endearing to people and they're
rooting for me and I got a few laughs,
you know,
I made a couple of fucking gay jokes,
whatever,
like,
you know,
and uh,
and before I left the left,
after that night I scheduled my return
and,
and before I came back I wrote,
I wrote a set and I came back and it
went reasonably well and I was thrilled.
Then I got over confident.
I was like,
Oh,
I'm just good at standup so I can come
back again and don't even know.
I don't try to work on the fucking act I
had written,
I'm like dominant to fucking God garb
and wing it.
And I bombed and I heard her and I
bombed again.
And then I was like scared to get back
to it and I was out of control with
drugs.
So that guy,
I was really dizzy,
it wasn't the time now,
once I got sober in Rehab then like
going to bars,
going to nightclubs,
that's just,
that's not on the table anymore.
Like again,
you've got to ask yourself do you have a
reason to go there?
And I didn't have any fucking reasons
but I had every reason to go to a comedy
club.
So that became like my goto thing at
night,
you know,
like from going with going out with a
girl,
you know,
it's like a thing.
I got a reason to be there and I go to
the comedy club and so I'm sitting in
the comedy club and in my early sobriety
and we're looking at the stage thinking
a,
she'd be on that stage,
I should be on that stage.
But I was like scared,
you know.
And then as the press machine was,
it wasn't even real.
It was the first name thing I even did
ostensibly to promote jackass three d
was this young Hollywood interview and
they said Adim cooks in there.
Just go barge genders interview.
It'll be great.
So I walk into Dean cooks,
interview on it,
and I meet him and I'm like,
hey dude,
like,
uh,
you know,
I've dabbled in standup but I want to
get serious about it.
I want to really dive in and fucking to
his credit man.
He said,
cool.
let's do it.
I'll give you my number.
Will get on stage at the,
at the Improv,
like,
uh,
in,
in a week a gave me his number and I
fucking wrote.
And I wrote,
I rode that whole fucking week and went
when the fucking practice of that shitty
little,
uh,
the open mic,
Marty's,
it's hilarious.
He wouldn't even know it was morning.
It's on Sunset Boulevard,
right by rock and roll routes.
It's a,
it's a hilarious little fucking hole in
the wall and stand open,
you know,
open mic.
And I went to,
you know,
sure enough,
I met Dean Cook at the Improv.
Like,
dude,
it was like two comics after Sarah
Silverman.
And then I go on and then Dane goes on
and right after Dane said he sat down
with me and fucking gave me notes.
The first thing he said was,
I'm not sending you back to the drawing
board,
which was like his way of saying that
the material I did like wasn't like
don't rewrite.
Like it's good,
he's just worried about your delivery
and your timing and from there I went to
the fucking tonight's laugh fighter
Danes there,
which is,
he took me under his wing,
you know,
like,
just like with regularity,
she'd go and I'd go and he'd go the
other way around and he'd sit me down
and give me notes.
That put so much fucking winded myself.
That's awesome.
I'm really grateful to Dane Cook for
that music through.
Oh yeah.
What's up with hermaphrodites their real
name to Intersex a couple years ago.
It's like the medical terminology was
changed.
So is there such thing as having a Dick
and pussy?
Yeah.
So there's a.
here's all the stats on which is born
with which,
and there's different one in 1000,
666 births.
So I don't know which is actually the
androgen insensitivity syndrome both.
So they don't necessarily use the term
hermaphrodites right?
Yeah.
It's so used to like in biology.
Oh,
I see.
So when it comes to.
Oh,
so there's like a list of.
It looks like there's like 30 of them.
How many are there?
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six.
Hold it.
When referring to humans,
I think they stopped using that word
because it made people feel bad.
Probably Jesus Christ.
So complete Gonadal Digen,
Isas,
oo.
One in 100.
50,000.
That can't be good.
Alpha reductase deficiency.
Five.
Vaginal agent.
SSS.
Imagine Vagina vaginal agent.
Emphasis that feel.
It sounds like you have an old pussy.
You're born.
I'm sorry.
Your baby was born with an old pussy.
He looked down.
It's like an old fucking pussy.
I don't even want to know what their is,
but only your vagina could be worse.
Things.
Phases.
Cute.
So there are hermaphrodites.
There are people that are born with a
vagina and Google are.
Is there people that are born with both
of a giant,
a penis?
Oh,
are people born with both a vagina and
penis?
Because it was too many medical terms
there.
I don't know which one of those would
apply.
Right.
It's Kinda like with that,
with little people.
And I hate that fucking term.
Well,
the thing about Dr drew is he's an
addiction specialist,
right?
So He.
How much does he even know about this
stuff?
I mean,
how much did he really learn about this
stuff?
And he's also an addiction specialist
who earnestly says that marijuana is
hugely addictive,
which is just.
I did,
I used to fucking used to do it a lot,
I'm sure.
But yeah,
here's the thing dude,
like I,
uh,
at one point,
um,
I was,
I was starting to have setting for this,
this chair can I humped uh,
uh,
as strange chicken,
her bed and tied the rubber and,
and not,
which I would do,
you know,
an entire Robert and non threw it on the
floor or fucking dog ate the rubber.
Right?
And like,
and um,
and it was her boyfriend's dog and I'm
thinking,
oh no,
the fucking dog.
Maybe take the rubber,
the rubber,
like the dog tempt them fucking rubber
for like a victory lap and it's kind of
driving.
It's going to look terrible for this
girl,
so I'm like,
following the dog around.
Ultimately the dog shit it out and it
was hilarious but I felt bad because
like,
you know,
I based,
it's kind of like sodomized him the dog
a little bit.
And so then I felt like to make it up to
the dog,
get the high when I owe,
I owe it to the dog to do it myself.
And I'm like,
because this is a funny bit like condom
for load in it and wow,
that was essentially,
that would be really fun.
But I got it in my head.
I'm going to swallow a condom,
but then I was like,
okay,
cool.
When I'm on tour,
when I'm on tour in Europe,
I'll fucking put weed in the condom,
tied in a knot and it'll be like a skit
where I've found minton international
drug smuggler skit.
I'll do it country and I'll fly to the
other country and shit it out.
And uh,
and I did it.
It was his fucking saga.
Actually.
I have a fucking epic they guy.
There's a huge tent pole a bit in my
standard right now about that whole.
I got arrested for international drug
smuggling and Sweden.
Did you?
I did.
And it's fucking ipad.
That's so classic.
Swallowing a condo.
Greatest fucking story ever did.
It's so fucking awesome.
Yeah,
I get it.
Yeah.
I spent such a get caught because I
fucking told the press like I was like,
at first I did it.
I did it.
It was so mad.
I didn't so big they want to try to
fucking swallow.
It got stuck in my throat and I'm
freaking the fuck out.
I'm turning out like.
And then I fly.
I fly from Norway to Sweden and a
Knoxville told me I was.
It was the nug.
See I didn't even take.
I didn't even break the buds off the
stem and it had a bucket of Moroccan
hash in there too.
To put Jesus in the same cognitive.
Yeah.
And I swallowed it.
Dick Dick was one of the jugs deep
throat in the incredible.
Oh,
show me in your fingers how big this
thing was.
It was uh,
I dunno,
I mean I have,
it's on video and that's it for my next
comedy special.
It's on video.
Yeah,
the filmed everything it was.
That was formative for my,
for my DVD at the visit online.
I'm sure it probably is.
But what's,
what,
what's so I'm so excited about my next
comedy special is that so many of the
stories I tell in my stand up or things
that happened on camera originally,
so I'm editing into editing into the
fucking actual standup kind of like you
do with the podcast,
like supporting foot archival footage,
which just demonstrates that,
that everything is not only not true.
It's not only truthful,
it's not even embellished,
but it's like,
it's like a 100 percent and saw like,
am just so excited to do that.
Uh,
yeah.
That's all my God.
Wait a minute.
It's hard to tell because the
perspective,
where's your fingers?
It's a fucking play it.
So they could say that's where I'm
swallowing.
I can click and go fucking massive.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It got stuck and people that are
looking,
it's like basically like an eight year
old here.
I just,
it's,
it's totally stuck in my throat.
Oh my God.
And you're throwing up blood trying to
throwing up blood.
Oh,
this is so crazy to see the inside of
your body up.
I was trying to swallow it.
It wouldn't go down.
I'm trying to Barf.
It wouldn't go.
It wouldn't come on.
Fly to Sweden because like my buddies
are like,
we got to take care of the hardship that
out ever took six and a half days at
Knox was active.
You're going to dive intestinal
strangulation because if I can get a
block at my intestines,
oh my God,
dude,
I got sorry.
Ticket Tuesdays to come out and when it
came out,
man,
you must pass my asshole exploded.
I don't want to tell all my jokes on the
podcast because that's fucking land.
A big important part of the day.
There's fucking the best bet.
I love it.
I mean I've,
I've,
I'm proud of what I'm doing on stage.
So are you saying that pot is a.
That was how I got in.
That's how I first did it.
Then I realized,
okay,
because filming wild boys,
every time we would like I would freak
the fuck out whenever we went to the Far
East because you know,
you're not going to be able to find weed
and that was not a case.
So I anytime I went to anywhere where I
wasn't competent I would be able to get
weed.
I sat there with my.
Before I go into the airport I sat there
with my fucking weed grinder and grind
it up like a ton and fucking compacted
so you know,
broke the buds off the steps and then I
would,
I would fill up and put them out like an
eighth in each condom,
whatever.
Night Nights and smaller pack it up and
I would swallow like six of them,
you know,
really doll.
Yeah,
I would say when you swallow those,
how long did it take to ship those ones?
Those ones that come up quick was one to
come out and,
and I don't know,
like one to two days,
like a,
of something like that many times you
swole condoms every day.
I went in,
when I went to Thailand,
I give them one onto Russia,
like a dad didn't think it was my
fucking thing.
I was like,
that was your thing was shitting out
your pot that you would smoke?
Yeah.
And it's either 70 when you lit it.
Did ever smell like a condom?
It never smelled like a condo dot the
day that say there's a lot of,
uh,
there's a lot of funny in that,
but I'm sure that's a psychological
issue.
It's not like physical addiction is what
we're talking about kids and addicted to
alcohol to the point where alcohol is
one of the most dangerous for addictions
because when you get onto these die from
it.
Sure.
Like that's how he mean winehouse died.
Like a lot of people think she died from
drugs.
She actually died because she went cold
Turkey off of alcohol.
I believe that it kills me.
I know that I'm a fucking true drug
addict is that I watched that
documentary,
amy,
and as I walked out of the fucking
theater,
I like,
fuck man,
I want to get so crazy.
That was the least glamorous portrayal
of drug addiction to ever,
ever just looked great to me.
I was like,
my God fucked out.
Well,
there's no,
there's no mistaking the fact that
somehow or another that what she was
doing with her life,
whether or not you could say that it was
the drugs or the state of mind that she
was in when she was taking the drugs.
She produced some fucking amazing music
man.
Right.
She just tapped into it.
Whatever it is like that.
She wasn't the hottest chick like,
you know,
you know that someone's talented when
they're not that hot chick and they're
fucking huge star for singing.
Oh yeah.
She was super talented.
She was saying,
well,
I mean,
there's a lot of hot chicks like Adele.
She's.
Who else?
Um,
I mean,
I'm sure you could find other ones.
I've never really sat down and thought
about it.
Exactly.
It's kind of a rule that you're supposed
to be really hot and the same.
Yeah,
I guess so.
And I'm trying to think like amy
winehouse.
Adele.
That's unfortunate,
isn't it?
It's bullshit.
Yeah.
For a girl,
right?
That's gotta suck,
Oh,
what Dick's for yards.
But see ya.
Who's that?
C is not super hot and I dunno know that
is.
She uh,
is a hugely popular singer.
I'm so out of the loop.
I'm not old man.
Who doesn't know what the fuck's going
on with the young kids today?
Kids today.
I get it there and he had to tell me
that little bow fakes the fact that he
was on a jet,
a private jet when he said that.
He said it was his jet and I told him he
got busted and he was flying on a
private jet and some of them was
actually on a commercial flight with him
and took a picture of him because they
saw it on instagram.
This motherfucker is full of shit.
He's right in front of me.
That's so fucking classic.
That's exactly like that dude bear
grylls.
Yes.
Very similar.
Same type of thing.
Well,
it's actually worse.
It's like he,
he set up his tent,
like Ferris Bueller with the bow thing
is indicative of an entire culture
shift.
It's just all about showing off your
flashlight shit and like showing that
you know,
we ball in here,
we bought it and I was watching a
fucking documentary vice documentary on
Youtube about a bay area hip hop and the
whole thing is they're like,
they're.
They're talking about how it's such a
fucking travesty that are the tech money
came in and,
and the area got gentrified headed.
The whole thing is they're like,
our land got gentrified and the rap
artists talk about their life and I got
millions like it doesn't.
It doesn't jive.
You can't be complaining about
gentrification and talking about your
millions.
Well,
not all hip hop does that,
you know,
there's like some socially conscious hip
documentary.
They were so stupid that complaining,
complaining that these people that make
the fucking very electronics they need
to make their music came in and I had a
terrible time in San Francisco.
Francisco trip.
It's my car broken into.
It was parked it outside of a fucking
vegetarian restaurant.
Granted
in the tenderloin.
It's terrible,
but it was fucking noon.
It was parked right outside the
restaurant and they fucking smashed on
window.
And then for the rest of the weekend I
was at Cobb's comedy club the rest of
the week and every single person I said,
yeah,
I got my fucking window,
smashed my shit stolen on my car.
Every person I mentioned that to you
said,
yeah,
that happened to me too.
And that's starting to happen in La too,
man.
What's always happened on La West
Hollywood there and smash and grab isn't
becoming a bit did in San Francisco to
the worst,
but it's always happened.
It's always been broke.
People that break into people's cars,
especially if you leave anything like
really obvious in the front seat,
it's visible,
visible.
That's was the biggest score that
whoever broken in my car,
I had my Super Pac,
I was getting ready to go.
Fucking fell on my super PAC is like,
plus I have the merchant money from
selling.
Fucking merge left in your car to I was
going to film and I didn't even fucking
thing about it.
Day there is like three minutes.
You didn't think that you are going to
park and one of the shittiest
neighborhoods in all of California with
a really valuable.
Yes,
Joe.
You've seen it like it's like.
It's like,
wow.
It's so weird.
Okay,
Joe.
I'm dumb.
I hit my head a lot.
Joe.
People don't know how bad the tenderloin
is.
I didn't know how bad it was and for me
like I'd like to add to what could
happen outside of a spiritual fucking
vegetarian restaurant,
which is right outside the window.
Plus we sat and sitting next to them.
We sat by the window so as to see the
car in our line of vision.
How's that possible?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Yeah,
San Francisco is a weird place now
because like the money that you have to
spend to buy a house there is so crazy
that it doesn't even make sense anymore.
Right?
Like they.
There was a house that was for sale for
over a million dollars and it was a
fucking tiny,
shitty shack that had to be torn down.
I mean,
there was literally nothing there and
people like this is the most piece of
ridiculous real estate in all of North
America.
Right.
It's all that tech money.
I lived there when I was a kid.
I lived there from age seven to 11.
I still magic show fisherman's wharf
when I was eight years old.
I think you were telling me that you're
in a car or you're talking with the al
about it,
but what?
We work to cops together.
Yeah,
but I used to live there when I was a
little kid and it was just,
you know,
this was during the Vietnam war is like
hippie time.
It was weird.
It was just all hippies and gay people
and it was a,
you know,
that was what San Francisco was forever
until this tech boom and now it's just
fucking insane money.
If you ever go on,
like I go on like that,
a APP,
Trulia,
it's like a real estate or art,
but I go,
what do they look?
What kind of houses they have in
Seattle?
Like,
let's look at houses just for goof.
Sure.
You look at San Francisco and you're
like,
what is 14 million by you in San
Francisco?
Holy Shit.
Are you getting fucked?
Right?
Like a regular house.
It's like $14 bucks.
West Vancouver is pretty fucked up too.
So a lot of tech money up there too.
I don't know what it is,
but it's tech money for whatever reason.
I guess it's just because you know,
everybody uses tech and just chunk tons
of money in it,
but those guys just seem to figure out a
way to make more money than anybody.
There's so much money in San Francisco
though.
It's crazy.
Right?
I know.
So you had a bad time at San Francisco
because you parked the car on the
tenderloin with a lot of money and a lot
of electronics,
like laptop,
Ipad Fuckin,
Seventy d,
every lens will three grand in cash or
are you doing.
I'm so you're doing like these shows
that you're filming them,
is that what you're bringing all this
electronics sometimes.
Yeah.
And sometimes I'm just filming for
whatever youtube you know now you did
your showtime special.
That was what,
a year and a half ago or so?
Yeah,
it was the end of 2015 and then it aired
in March of 2016.
Yeah,
because remember you get in touch with
me saying you need so much choke Johan,
Texas.
I'm like,
I know the guy.
I fucking loved him.
Kennedy MTM.
So thrilled.
The top of my plugin especially came out
on showtime.
Oh,
that's awesome.
I really fucking people get it somewhere
other than showtimes that available on
Netflix and those things.
He had um,
uh,
the showtime showtime on demand.
And then Vimeo and I thought it was on
Vimeo.
Yeah,
I think that,
that uh,
it was,
I guess there was tied up for two years
before it can go on Netflix.
So No.
So is it available now?
Not yet.
Not yet soon.
Yeah.
That's cool.
I'm fucking stoked.
Time on,
on how that came out.
Are you going to do another one?
Yeah,
like I said,
man,
I'm working on,
I'm working on doing a comedy special
where I edit in archival footage,
which is sort of makes it a docu comedy
special,
which I have,
which I love.
Do people or people born that have a
penis and vagina.
We figured that out.
I was looking up a yes and no.
I would say I forgot what I was reading
most of the headmaster after that comes
from having ovaries and testicles that
are maybe both at the same time.
There's a pseudo hermaphrodites or also
true hermaphrodites,
and there's some sort of true
hermaphrodite is someone who has both
genitals.
Yeah.
This is the best picture,
true Hermaphrodites,
internal sex organs,
tissue,
and some cases.
That means that a ball in one side and
ovary and the other and others,
that means hybrid beasties notice,
oh my God.
Over testes to the naked eye.
They're external genitals tend to be
iffy.
Maybe it's a big clit,
perhaps the urban dictionary,
scientific scientific document per
chance.
It's some unholy.
Pino vaginal mismatched.
Pseudo hermaphrodites have the
chromosome and internal sex organs of
one gender while the external
protuberances are.
Again,
anyone's guest photo,
click that.
Nothing.
Oh,
that's a hardcore clear.
That's.
That makes sense.
That is a Hermaphrodite,
right?
Tibi.
This page also has something called A.
There's a is an ant eater.
What'd you say?
Double Penis.
And then there's this thing down at the
bottom I found,
which is this?
Never heard of this.
Persistent chloe,
Chloe,
one in 20,000 female verse Gianna and
Vagina and Urethra coverage converged
into one nauseatingly funnel like drain
and Chol.
Located somewhere in the area between
the clitoris and the buttocks.
Poopy and vaginal sludge.
Mingle.
Freely corrective surgeries.
Costly,
complicated and risky.
Don't click on that photo.
Um,
what about the double vagina photo?
Click on that bitch.
See what the fuck's going on,
but not.
Oh Jesus.
There's one next to the other one.
Whoa.
Why does it look like that?
It looks like a chicken.
Like an autopsy,
right?
Yeah.
That's not good.
That's when it didn't work out.
Um,
let's go with the double penis.
Let me see.
Adult Penis picture is that real?
And this isn't one of those dudes that
slices it.
That's a cred that micro penis.
Things like bomber man click to penises.
Oh,
it's true guys.
Double Deck.
No,
that's a slice.
That's a.
This is websites.
Bullshit image.
That's a 1955.
Oh,
okay.
So it's not a split.
It's just he's just got a broken,
doubled dick thing going on.
He's peeing out of his clit whole.
It's like the Lizard Dude that Kinda
tongue as a lot of people do that.
That's a real common to cutting the
tongue cutting the Deq.
They split their dick down the Middle
and then the pee comes out and just a
big Ole splatter and wow.
People just.
They just do.
You know?
It's a weird world.
We live in Steevo.
So another thing about my comedy
special,
that guy's got to double Dick's pig.
Fatties really does.
Maybe you could donate one to a friend
with a little bit.
They do that now.
They do in Doug Dick replacement
surgeries.
But like if someone had an accident or
something happened to their Dick,
they give them a penile replacement
where they'll,
someone will die and they'll take his
dick and sew it onto you and it works.
You can get an erection and everything
and they do it for a soldier that got an
explosion.
I thought,
I remember reading that.
I do not remember.
I remember the first guy that got it
done though.
I believe it was a 50 year old man and
something happened to him and he was
dickless for like a year.
Tough year.
Yeah.
Well he kind of sewed back up memory.
He could.
He did porn when it was done.
It was just the head of his Dick.
She cut it in half.
She basically just slopped the top off
of that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'll never forget and I didn't even know
that this is until somebody explained
to me on the show that this actually
happened,
but uh,
Ozzy Osbourne's wife was on some talk
show that she was doing for awhile and
she was joking around about some woman
cut her husband's Dick off and threw it
in a garbage disposal and they were
laughing about it.
I'm just laughing,
thinking about his willie spinning
around inside that garbage pillar.
And I went,
wow,
what double standards with crazy double
standards,
because you could,
you imagine a group of men sitting
around laughing about a guy cutting off
a chick's pussy and throwing it in a
garbage disposal.
There's,
I can't imagine a scenario where you
would not only laugh about that,
but laugh about it on television and
think it's okay.
But somehow or another it was okay for
her to laugh about a guy losing his dick
and having a chopped off and thrown into
a fucking garbage disposal.
So weird,
creepy double standard.
Right?
But at the same time,
like if you think like,
I'm kind of close to this because
sometimes people want to make like a
female version of jackass where girls do
like terrible shit and,
and hurt themselves on purpose.
That's never gonna work.
And it boils down to a hormonal thing
because like men with testosterone,
the idea is that,
you know,
we're providers and we're supposed to be
like macho and prove that we're tough.
And so it,
it,
it becomes funny to see a guy fail and
get hurt.
Like that's fun.
And because it's but not.
But with,
but with women,
with women,
they're their maternal.
They're nurturers there,
so it's not cool to see them get hurt.
They blur the line a little bit when
they tied the guy down and cut his dick
off and threw it in the garbage
disposal.
This is not a like a blurry line here.
Alright,
this is.
This is.
Okay.
Joe Is in jail for the rest of her life
because she chopped his dude's cock off.
Hey Man.
It's just.
I'm just saying it's weird that they
thought it was okay to laugh about.
It's not.
I mean it's horrific that people do
horrific things to each other.
It's no more horrific than a woman does
it to a man that Amanda's to a woman and
people have done horrible shit to women
for forever.
But it's never funny.
Did they make it funny?
Because a lot of people can make a lot
of things funny.
Shane,
funny.
Ozzy Osbourne's wife.
Not very funny.
No,
it was just gross.
It was just mean.
But it was weird that all these women
thought it was funny.
They call,
he lost his dick.
Like whoa.
Like it's seem real,
but I guess it's also because like,
you know,
like what you're saying,
it's like there's something funny about
a man getting fucked up.
Like a lot of people feel like that
about watching women fighting.
There's people that I know that are
super uncomfortable.
It's like watching a Yoni and Jim Check
fight because she beats the fuck out of
checks and balances are facing and cuts
them up.
Right?
Like,
do you watch a watch?
Major
Fan of UFC?
I really fucking love that shit.
I think it's,
it's incredible.
How not only did women,
you know,
I mean Dana White said forever,
there will never be women.
And then
now not only are there women but there
like the headliners,
the headliners often.
Um,
this past weekend it was a co main event
that you want to check and it was a real
good fight because the woman she was
fighting,
which was tough as fuck and she took a
serious beating,
but there was a fight that she did you
want to check against?
Um,
see you pull up the highlights.
A young Jay check versus Jessica Panay.
Try spelling her name.
Good luck.
I don't even know how to support her.
It's so hard to spell it into the people
just call her Yolanda champion.
They don't even try with her last name
because it's like aj and z and then a
fucking eat and then some letters that
don't even exist in the English
language.
But um,
she beat this girl up so bad that it
was,
it was fucking disturbing.
I mean,
she fucked this girl up.
She's,
yeah,
there's a lot of blood in this one.
Oh,
it's horrible.
Well,
the girl just just did not belong in the
ring with her.
I mean in the cage with her.
She's from Holland.
Poland,
yeah.
Multiple time world champion.
She was before she ever got into mma,
she was one of the best strikers on the
planet.
And if you go like deep into the fight,
she just packs her apart for the first
couple of rounds and then by the time
you're deep in the ground,
she's just a mask of blood and you want
to.
It's just beating the fuck out of her
and smashing her in the face with elbows
and cutting her up.
And then the final barrage when she,
when they stopped the fight,
like you see blood pouring out of her
nose.
It's coming out.
And the girl Jessica Panay all due
credit to her.
That girl is tough as fuck.
Like,
look at this.
She is a mask of blood and swelling and
you and Jay check is just a fucking
demon.
She's just kicking at her and smashing
her face.
And her face is,
comes from the other girl.
Oh yeah.
Well she probably got hit a few times
herself.
I mean it was a fight.
I'm sure she got scratched and cut a
little bit.
Was just know if she got hit at all,
which I'm sure she did.
But look at that,
that these short elbows like look at it
across my face.
I mean it's just.
And you see also that she's just having
a hard time taking it and this is the
final barrage.
She steps forward.
Elbows are in the face and just boots
dog shit out of her.
And uh,
I had some friends that were watching
this that weren't in a May fans and they
were like,
fuck this,
I can't watch this.
Look at this.
Bang,
look at that.
That was final barrage.
Oh,
no way.
But I just had a lot of thoughts on the
same time,
like thinking man,
what an honor to sit next to Joe Rogan
as he essentially commentates fight.
Like a lot of people would want to do
that.
And then,
uh,
and then I was,
you know,
like,
I'm such a fan of yours,
you know,
and I don't want to keep spending years
to.
We're friends.
We don't really have to talk like we're
fans of each other.
We're just buddies.
Then I thought,
fuck did this one coming up is an
anaheim where a cormier and Jon Jones
exciting fucking thing is.
How do I want to.
Yeah.
Oh Dude,
you're the man.
That's it.
I fucking love sitting right next to me.
My Dad's gonna be in town to.
My Dad's going to do.
I'll give you two tickets.
One for your dad.
Ah,
fuck you and your dad.
I want to meet your dad.
I want to try the store.
When you're 13,
you went to motley crew with them.
My Dad's gods.
That wouldn't even be a priority for
him.
I don't think.
That's awesome.
That's cool.
I am so excited.
I wanted to ask too,
like,
you know,
for all the shit talking,
people have to promote the fights,
but like Daniel Cormier and Jon Jones,
no matter who wins the end of the fight,
they're going to shake each other's
hand.
Right.
I hope so.
Is it common like what we saw with Ronda
Rousey not shaking me shit.
Fucking armbar somebody they tap out and
then they get up and go to shake your
hand and you won't do it like that.
Well,
I think that mentality that Rhonda has,
she's like,
she's mercenary in there.
I mean,
and it wasn't over when it was over to
her for her wasn't a competition.
It was life.
It was,
it was life or death.
I don't know man.
I mean that same thing is probably why
she's not fighting anymore,
you know,
like her animosity and our emotions were
so riding on that thing.
And then when she lost,
and then when she lost again in
devastating fashion,
that's also the reason why there was so
much backlash.
Whereas someone who's really loved,
like randy coture,
randy couture would lose a fight and no
one talked.
I mean,
I'm sure someone talked trash about him,
but no one's opinion of him deferred
when he lost because you such a good
guy.
And because when he,
when he won,
you know,
after the fight,
he would always pick the guy up and
shake their hand and hugged them.
And he was always a gentleman.
And when people have that sort of a
mentality,
you know,
like,
here's a perfect example.
This past weekend,
Dustin poor ea and Eddie Alvarez had a
fight and the fight was stopped because
of an illegal blow that Eddie Alvarez
accidentally landed on Dustin Poirier.
And the crowd was booing.
Eddie Alverez and Dustin poray yelled at
the crowd,
don't boo this man.
Like we were in a fight and he's not a
dirty fighter.
And he made a mistake and they,
first of all,
Eddie Alvarez,
I was closed.
He could barely see.
He was completely on Queer Street,
he had been almost knocked unconscious
and he hit this dude in the clench with
a couple of knees and the referee didn't
stop.
I mean he thought they were illegal,
you know,
he's in the chaos of a crazy cage fight,
but to have those two dudes after the
fight,
bolt or bloody and battered,
both of them are just like exhausted
from a war.
Right.
And I'm interviewing the both of them
side by side and to have dustin poirier
step in to defend Eddie Alvarez who just
need him illegally in the face telling
the crowd,
don't boo this man.
Like he was literally upset and then
they shook hands.
There's something beautiful about that
and I think people to me,
people like the animosity,
but they also really liked the fact when
the animosity squashed after the fight
and people hug it out,
they really do like that.
Yeah.
And I think that there's.
I think that there's a parallel
with comedians who don't want to accept
other comedians and then that.
And then there's you who's just not
insecure and wants more fucking comedy.
I love comedy.
I love comedians.
There's some comedians that want to be
the only person that's funny and they
also bring people that suck with them on
the road.
That's one thing to say.
I can't stand it.
Oh,
that's so common guys will do.
They stack the deck,
they'll bring someone on the road with
them.
That's terrible.
I tried to bring the funniest young
guys.
I can find an Edwards.
Yeah,
Ian.
And this weekend Tony and Ian,
those guys are national headliners,
you know,
and,
but I bring both of them on the road
with me.
I hadn't joined the years and I had one
show and uh,
uh,
November 2011 and it was my first
theater show in La and this was like,
I'm going to have everybody that matters
to me like every,
you know.
And uh,
and I asked Ian Edwards to open for me.
That's awesome.
And uh,
the fucking stoked.
He's an alum was just so struck that he
even did it and I loved that.
He's so much better than me.
He's a really fucking good guy too.
He's another guy that he spent too much
time doing other things other than doing
standup and it was one of the things
that I always tell comics,
so you've got to be careful of those
honeypot jobs,
like writing for a show,
like a lot of really good comics wind up
losing their standup careers because
they develop a writing career and they
they,
they look,
Ian should be a national headlight or in
big theaters all over the world.
He really all of the country and all
over the world who really should be,
he's that good,
but because of the fact that he spent so
much time writing on sitcoms,
he didn't tour enough and he didn't put
out enough material.
Like he only has one cd out.
He's been doing comedy as long as me.
Even Edwards and I started doing comedy
together in 1990.
That's when I met him.
I met him in 1990 or 91 in New York and
I've known him for ever.
He was when I made my first video is
1990.
Wow.
It's a long time,
man.
Fuck that dude.
But yeah,
my thoughts are that we should,
I mean if you like,
like everybody gets into comedy because
they love it,
right?
That's why you get into it.
You want,
you want to watch,
you know,
you see a guy like dice clay or Kennison
or prior or whoever it is that inspired
you and you see them,
Kevin Hart,
no name your per person.
You see them.
You want to be like,
wow,
that was awesome.
I want to see that guy again.
You know,
and you want to go see comedy.
And that's why.
That's why I got into it.
Like to get into it and then all of a
sudden they want to be the only one
that's funny.
It's crazy.
To me,
it doesn't even make any sense.
And to not like the other comedians.
It's just like you're robbing yourself
of inspiration.
But there's a lot of comics like that.
They won't watch the other comedians.
They don't want to see them.
And when the comics are doing good,
they get upset,
you know,
they're like light,
um,
early let them earlier.
Like I've seen people say it's totally a
question of being insecure.
It definitely is.
It's also,
I think it's,
it's a,
it's a famine mindset.
And the famine mindset is this mindset.
Like there can only be one,
like you could only be.
It can only all come to me.
It has to all come to me like no one
else
can,
but it's no.
Who's that snoop Dogg Song Song.
It's no fun if the homies can't have
some.
But it's true.
You don't want to be the only one who's
doing well.
That's crazy.
It's just not a good thinking.
It's not a good way of thinking rather.
And Fuck,
I'm excited for,
for Anaheim.
Oh,
you're going to have time.
It's great car to.
As sad as it stands right now,
there's a lot of issues.
I'm like getting these cards to actually
show,
like to play out because guys get
injured,
they get disqualified or.
Yeah.
But I mean when you're getting to.
Yeah,
they get caught doing something.
Yeah.
Sorry for interrupting that.
I watched that hurt business documentary
on Netflix.
I haven't seen Daniel cormier the
fucking like a knee injury and is trying
to get healthy again and fuck that
documentaries and I haven't seen it.
It's so incredible.
Like the way,
I mean almost like the focus of it is I
get,
we're going to spotlight like a number
of these personalities from the UFC and
really showed us how fucking tragic it
is.
They put so much into it and then they,
you know,
they had their careers for whatever it's
worth.
And then when it's all said and done,
they just got nothing to fucking show
for it and it's just so fucking trash.
Well,
you can't think that you're going to
have something to show for it.
That's the thing.
If you're lucky and you become a condom,
mcgregor who is like one in a million or
you become,
you know,
uh,
George St Pierre who retires as the
champion.
You're,
you're really,
really unusual.
But for everyone else,
you have to do it because you love doing
it.
And if you do it because you love doing
it and that's what you want to do,
then you should do it and you will bank
a lot of money if you're successful.
But there's this thing that people have
when they see a guy like floyd
mayweather and they say,
well,
hey,
boxers make millions of dollars.
Look Floyd me whether made hundreds of
millions of dollars.
No,
no,
no.
Floyd mayweather makes hundreds of
millions of dollars.
Not Boxers,
like Gennady Golovkin who,
who's one of the best boxers in the
world.
He can't even sell 200,000 paper views
like his last paper view by,
I think it was like a hundred and
50,000,
which is insanely low to the point where
it's very difficult for promoters even
get behind him unless he's fighting
someone like Canelo Alvarez,
which is his next fight,
will he'll make some money in that
fight,
but guarantee you he ain't making very
good money.
Like with a hundred and 50,000 paper
views.
And he's a multiple time world champion
and like a fantastic amateur fighter.
One of the best in the world.
It's about being a star and a promoter
is not responsible to give a fighter a
bunch of money if they're not earning a
bunch of money.
It's a business and the business is
people want to pay to see you.
Why do they want to see you?
Do they want to see you because you
trash talk or do they want to see you
because you're Anderson Silva and you'll
fight like you're in.
You're in the matrix or do they want to
see you because you're Ronda Rousey?
The first ever woman asked kicker that
we've ever seen like this.
Well,
whatever reason it is that they want to
see you.
That reason is why you can make a shit
ton of money.
It's not that you just deserve a shit
ton of money because it's hard to do and
that's where a lot of people get that
wrong in their head.
They get that wrong in their head.
Well,
it's show business,
but it's also athletics,
so it's a very bizarre combination of
two worlds.
Do you think that conor mcgregor is
doing a disservice to myself by putting
so much attention on,
like just putting his whole UFC career
on hold for this mayweather thing?
No.
Um,
because ultimately he can only fight for
so long and he stands to win.
Who knows how much money?
I mean he can make.
It could be as much as $100,000,000 sort
of fight.
It's going to be insane asking you guys
to pass up on the opportunity to make
$100,000,000 is kind of crazy.
That said he's fighting boxing.
No,
no,
no.
It doesn't matter.
It's not.
The way boxing works is you get a purse,
you know,
like the way UFC works is different and
often criticized and I think rightly so
is that you have a wind money and a show
money.
So say if you were going to fight Jamie
and they set it up where you,
uh,
you fight,
you make $50,000 to show and then
another 50 if you win.
A lot of people have a real hard time
with that and I think they should
because you're doing your best.
You're giving your best performance
regardless of whether or not you win.
No one's going to fight harder,
I don't think,
at least to get that wind bonus.
These guys are trying to win.
They're fucking gladiators,
you know?
I mean,
I think you should have a purse and that
should be what you get paid and you
fight your best and that's what you get
paid.
Like this idea that you're double is
gonna,
you know you're going to come your way
if you get the judge's nod.
Meanwhile the judges get shit wrong all
the time and to have your future like
have $50,000 or 100 that or who knows
what the number is on the line due to
someone else's interpretation of it.
Or you can get injured and one up losing
or anything of that.
But like I think that's kind of fucked
up.
The thing about the condom mcgregor,
floyd mayweather fight.
If,
if,
if it's tennis,
you'd get the money if you win.
Yeah,
but that's different.
First of all,
it's not a fight.
Okay.
Because you can play tennis.
Match every weekend.
Try fighting every weekend.
We'd be dead in a month.
You know,
a cure.
This US president.
Yeah,
they agreed to sign a deal with Florida.
That doesn't mean anything because floyd
mayweather hasn't agreed to.
The deal has been negotiated.
Connor has agreed,
so that's what that means,
but here's the deal.
Let's be honest about this as much as
possible.
This is a boxing match between conor
Mcgregor,
a guy who's never had a real
professional boxing match.
It was a really good amateur boxer,
an hour in Ireland who is a real
multiple division world champion,
combat sports fighter.
No doubt about that,
but an a striker,
no doubt about that,
but he's fighting one of the best
boxers,
if not the best boxer ever.
Most likely.
This is not gonna work out well for him.
If you had to guess,
that's my honest take on it.
The only way it could work out well is
if floyd takes them lightly.
Conocophillips.
Him,
connor mugs him kind of does some like
old school.
Bernard Hopkins,
Shit like this ties him up.
Rough sum up inside the clench,
hits them with some real hard shots or,
or does something fucked up to them.
I mean,
who knows,
had bought some.
I mean,
that's what Victor Ortiz tried to do to
him.
I guess you can also say that,
um,
that uh,
he doesn't really stand there.
It's a win win for connor because if he
loses,
of course he was going to lose.
Yeah.
And also floyd is not a vicious puncher.
Floyd's not knowing.
Never was.
No,
no,
he never was he.
He is an amazing boxer,
but he was very brittle.
Hands.
He breaks his hands a lot and he can
knock you out like you knocked out
Victoria.
But he knocked out victorious because
you're just standing in front of him.
He knocked out ricky Hatton who is a
smaller fighter,
but he doesn't knock out most guys.
He stuns them,
he sticks them with some hard shots.
But Connor has got a really good chin
and he's a much bigger guy.
So the odds are if even if connor gets
worked,
he's just going to get out boxed for 12
rounds and get embarrassed and just with
at a bunch of punches and flow is not
going to be anywhere near him or he can
catch him.
I mean it is possible that you can catch
them,
but it's not likely the odds are going
to be huge in floyd made with his
favorite.
If I had a gas it's going to be like 20
to one or something crazy like that.
I'm not an odds maker but.
But I do know movement and I know boxing
and just just,
just a big difference between what a guy
like floyd mayweather can do and a guy
like conor can do when it comes to the
actual boxing skills.
But there's also,
there's another factor too that connor
has been fighting with small gloves and
I was going to be fighting with larger
gloves.
What size?
Gloves they agree on for the fight.
If Floyd smart,
he's going to make them fight with 10
ounce gloves,
you know,
because probably connor will want to
watch were eight.
I Dunno what,
what weight class they have the cutoff
in like a lighter weight classes.
They use eight ounce gloves and heavier
these 10 ounce gloves,
you know,
so it's like that was a stipulation in
the Marvin Hagler and sugar Ray Leonard
Fight Sugar Ray Leonard wanted the
bigger gloves when a heavier gloves
because he's fighting a big heavy
puncher like Hagler,
so they might make some sort of a
decision to go with larger gloves,
but floyd's a fucking 49 and oh,
multiple division world boxing champion
and connor has never had a professional
boxing fight.
That's really what it is.
It's interesting.
I mean I want to see it.
Don't make no mistake about it.
When the first bell rings,
I'll have my popcorn ready,
bro.
Well you'll probably be right there.
I don't think so.
No,
I think it be home.
Yeah,
I think I'll be watching that from home.
I think that's a.
whoever does commentary on that.
It's going to be probably boxing people.
It's like if you had Max Kellerman and
Jim Lampley doing commentary on Floyd
Mayweather fighting conor mcgregor in an
mma fight,
I think that would be an embarrassment.
That'd be ridiculous.
Just as ridiculous as it would be for me
to do commentary on Connor Fighting
Floyd in a boxing match.
Unless they wanted to have a combination
of an MMA judge and a or an mma,
a commentator and a box and commentator
maybe.
Perhaps I would do it with Max
Kellerman.
I'm a big fan of that guy.
Like that guy a lot.
I think that would be kind of
interesting,
but most likely I'll be at home watching
it.
You know,
I'd like to see it live.
Maybe I'm like maybe sit ringside.
We'd be kind of interesting to see that.
It's going to be a crazy,
interesting experience to see what
connor can do and I know he's been
working like almost exclusively on his
boxing for months and months and months
in preparation for this.
Here's the thing that mother fucker can
put you into orbit with one punch.
That's a fact.
You know,
like if you look at this past weekend is
a perfect example.
When I said I'm about Eddie Alvarez and
Dustin poray having this crazy war.
Connor worked both of those guys with
one punch with,
I mean with Eddie.
He softened him up with a few punches
before he marked him,
but he,
he had him on Queer Street with one
punch and he murked dustin poirier with
one punch.
I mean he's just,
he hits fucking hard.
This,
this guy for Rasa hobbies,
a very famous mma coach and he said it
best.
He said,
connor has a touch of death.
Like he just,
he just fucking,
he just collapsed dudes in Zap.
Some ridiculous speed and accuracy and
when he does your Foxville,
the question is whether or not it can be
able to do that to floyd motherfucking
mayweather and most likely it's going to
be nowhere near him when those punches
come flying.
I mean he's a wizard ever watched like
Floyd Mayweather,
defensive highlight reel,
but it's just him kind of running
backward know him just moving away from
punches,
bending at the hips.
He's not a runner,
so he flew.
People think of Floyd's or runner.
Floyd doesn't run.
He's not like running away from guys who
stands right in front of Dude's.
He stands right in front of dudes and
maybe backs up slightly or moves to the
side,
but he's just so knowledgeable when it
comes to boxing and he has such a deep
understanding of where to be at the
right time and where the punches can
come from.
The left comes from here,
that means a right to come in this way
and he's nowhere near that.
He's over here and that means after the
right look like what can you stand in
front of them when you watch him,
the way he's able to like slide out of
the way a shit.
I mean dudes just don't fucking hit him
very often.
He's been hit least or less than any
world champion that's had 49 fights.
I would say that he probably has the
most successful defensive career and the
history of boxing.
He's,
I mean he's literally been tagged hard
maybe five,
six times in his entire career and he
stands in front of some of the best
fighters in the world,
like Canelo Alvarez mean Canelo was
younger than it was a few years ago and
Canelo wasn't as good as he is now,
but he just stands right in front of
guys and pop them in the face and just
understands how to move.
Like that kind of shit.
Like when you watching this highlight
reel,
you watch them master like young
fighters.
They should,
they should watch his defensive
movements and abilities I think almost
above all others,
except now this new guy,
facility Loma Chenko,
who I think his rivals,
anybody that's ever lived in terms of
his movement,
his ability to move and his,
his positioning and footwork.
I think he's as good as it's ever been,
but you know,
he is only got like nine professional
fights or something like that.
He just hasn't really.
Luckily this Oscar de la Hoya standard
right in front of him and he can't
fucking head him.
He's throwing all these punches like you
that mom won my mail Marquez,
he pops them and just swooped slides
right out of the way.
Sorry,
not here.
And unbelievable work ethic like Floyd
Mayweather will go to a club,
go to a nightclub in Vegas,
hang out,
drink water,
hang out with everybody,
get all the accolades.
Ladies and gentlemen floored everybody
goes crazy.
Lights in hundred dollar bills.
Then he know what he does.
People will drive his Rolls Royce and
he'll run.
He'll run the vegas strip of run miles
and then go to the gym 3:00 in the
morning and do fucking 15 rounds in the
heavy bag.
He's an animal.
I mean his,
his work ethic and his mind and his
determination and focus and I guarantee
you,
man,
if he's getting ready for Floyd,
mayweather is getting ready for.
I'm conor Mcgregor.
He's going to be in tip top shape again,
man.
He's not.
He's never going to come in and slept
in.
It's gonna.
Be Fun.
But why has he got to be so such a Dick?
Because that's how I made all that
money.
It's because we were talking about
before,
like what it like the shell business is
the show business aspect of it is having
p like he used to be pretty boy floyd
mayweather.
That's it.
They used to call them but it wasn't
really making any money.
You know,
he became rich when he became floyd.
Money Mayweather when he started talking
all this shit and people want him to get
his ass kicked and he wasn't getting his
ass kicked.
Like people are paying to see him.
Not necessarily because they like
they're paying to see him because they
want to see them get fucked up because
he's a huge star and it became a huge
star by fucking with people talking a
lot of shit.
Talking about a gradient is showing all
of his watches and all of his jewelry
and all.
He's got this crazy house in Vegas and
you know,
it's the,
it's really the controversy like
domestic violence through went to jail
for beating up girls.
You know,
like there's a lot of controversy
involved in him and that's one of the
reasons why people wanted to see him
fight.
They want to see him lose.
He didn't lose.
He went all the way to the bank.
I mean he tied rocky Marciano's record
for having the most successful fights
ever.
Forty $9,
zero as a champion.
It's not unheard of.
Unheard of.
And Rocky Marciano's record is bullshit
because rocky Marciano Italians right
now going crazy with the rubbish dump
past.
It's pretty much agree that rocky
Marciano fought his brother and at least
one fight early in his career.
So it was like a fake fight to pull that
up.
See if you've.
That's been,
that's been validated.
I'm pretty sure I've read that,
that rocky Marciano had like a fixed
fight with his brother back in the day.
You know,
like a guy like rocky Marciano was a
murderous puncher.
It's probably like he would show up for
fighting.
People didn't want to fight them and
like the people that paid to see him,
like,
what are we going to do?
I'm like,
damn my brother,
I'll get in there.
So his brother gets in there and it goes
down to a body shot or something.
I don't know.
I don't know how it played out,
but we're lucky we're not in that
business.
Do you think you have brain damage from
Tim Kennedy dropping you off in your
head?
How about just getting flooded in the
head by some of the best fighters in the
world?
I think I'm in pretty good shape with
all that.
Seemed fun.
Look,
Anthony Rumble Johnson,
who was one of the best fighters in the
world,
just retired and he did an interview
recently and uh,
today the interview came out.
We said brain damage is a big concern
and he's a guy,
gives everybody brain damage.
Have you ever seen rumble fight?
Most terrifying knockout artists in mma?
In my opinion.
And he retired because he's worried
about someone doing that to him.
He's like,
I don't want brain damage.
He was like,
I want,
I want other things in my life.
It was also interesting because he's one
of the best fighters in the world and he
said,
I'm not really a fighter.
He goes,
I'm an athlete.
It was really good at fighting.
I thought it was fascinating because it
shows so much awareness.
Shows what a smart guy he is,
but he's really kind of aware of who he
is.
Fuck that dude.
So Anaheim you.
They're down a suicide.
It's a good one too.
I hope nobody fucks up before the fight.
They almost kind of brought this past
weekend.
You should check out that show the
business business.
This past weekend,
Daniel Cormay hit John Jones in the face
with a water bottle at a press
conference and John Tried to chuck one
at him and they almost bald and people
got water bottles at the press
conferences.
Well they now they drained the monster
energy cans.
So when you see those monster energy
drinks that are sitting there on the
dance,
those are fake.
The real monster energy drinks,
but they have to drink them all or empty
them out before they get up there.
Right.
So exciting.
It's so exciting.
Just the this John John's.
That was so interesting that that a
press conference where Jon Jones is
talking all the positive like,
no,
I want to show that you can get back on
your feet and then says,
wait,
hold on a second.
These backstage you telling me I'm the
biggest puts he ever saw and then
they'd.
Yeah,
that's fascinating.
The way that played out.
Well John is starting to come clean now
trying to be more of himself and this
past weekend they had a press
conference.
He said that he was fucking doing
cocaine all weekend long before he beat
him.
Well,
Dennis said Danny was talking all this
shit.
What is this fight even though that
happened?
Who knows if John gets caught doing
cocaine or sandblast and a prostitute.
What is sandblasting?
But it's hilarious.
Hilarious term.
Dale's funny man.
I did commentary within this funny
fucking dude man.
That on your story.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And so anyway,
when John said that I beat you after I
did cocaine for a weekend,
but it was like,
oh shit.
It's like I liked that John is being
himself.
That's,
that's,
that'll serve him better than all this
fake shit.
Like I'm just a good guy and uplifting.
Yeah.
Well he doesn't want to be to,
but when it comes to like actual
fighting,
he's a fucking straight up killer.
Jon Jones is a killer.
That's,
I mean,
you don't get to be the youngest ever
UFC champion if you're not a killer.
He got,
he showed up.
He fought Mauricio Shogun who,
uh,
in his UFC title fight,
who is a legend in Brazil.
His opening move was a flying knee.
He threw a flying knee and Maricio
Shogun Hua.
That is just crazy.
I mean,
you have to be such a gangster to even
think about doing that to a guy like
she's not feeling feeling amount.
He just leapt in and through a fucking
flying knee it show guns face and caught
him and beat his ass and stopped him
when he was like 22 won the world title,
Ms Dot.
It was bananas,
you know,
John was something special and still is,
but it's gonna,
you know,
it's going to be a Ra,
a long,
tough fight with him and cormier this
time.
I think it's going to be fun.
It's going to be there.
I can't wait.
Yeah,
I just hope the car doesn't fall apart.
You know,
cards fall apart.
So hard to get through a camp without
getting injured.
Like we're in danger of losing tj
dillashaw versus a cody garbrandt for
the bantamweight title.
Cody cody,
cody garbrandt right now is in Germany,
getting some shit done to his back and
he's getting Regena keen done on his
back to deal with a bulging disc that's
been bothering me.
Like,
um,
I followed him on twitter and then he
followed me back.
Oh,
that's cool.
That's dope.
It's just strikingly handsome guys.
Very handsome.
Beautiful Man.
Bad motherfucker too.
That was the best fight of that night.
Dominick Cruz,
him and dominick Cruz.
Yeah.
Well,
not only that,
but I mean he's fighting a guy who was
consensus top two or three pound for
pound fighter in the world and Dominick
Cruz and he still lit them up.
Yeah.
That's a big fight.
And,
and the bravado that.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I was break dancing and shit improvising
after he dropped him and knocked him
down.
He was posing kid finished Mba.
He was telling us about that.
I don't know about that.
I mean,
if he thought he could have finished and
we would have tried to finish him,
he realized that dom was hurting Stan,
do you want to humiliate him?
He wanted to fuck with his head because
dom,
Dominick Cruz,
his whole game,
a big part of it was getting inside your
head be fucked with the wrong guy
because cody grew up getting fucked with
so like,
you start fucking with him.
He's like,
Oh,
I'm home here.
Like I like fucking with people.
Come on,
fuck with me.
I'll fuck with you.
Like if you want to be like reasonable
and respectful,
he'll be respectful,
be respectful.
But if you want to talk shit to him.
Oh he's a black belt and talking shit.
So it was like dominick Cruz just kind
of bit off more than he could chew when
it came to the shit talking and really
fired cody up.
So when cody dropped him and then
started posing and then dominic has to
kind of get it back and he couldn't get
it back.
So we got kind of a little bit out of
his,
uh,
his comfort level.
It's just a fascinating aspect of
fighting the trash,
talking in the mental warfare.
Yeah.
No,
there's a lot to it.
Don't.
Don't ever do that,
dude.
Don't ever let anybody talk you into
doing that.
I know Knoxville,
he
did that boxing match with butter being
that was so hard to watch.
It's terrible.
How bad was he?
Fucked up after that fight.
I know it's not the words for Knoxville.
What is he doing these days?
Right now he's filming a movie in South
Africa based on a true story about an
amusement park in New Jersey called
action park,
which was notoriously the most dangerous
a amusement park like lots of people
died on their rides.
Everybody that worked there was
intoxicated and fucked up other working
and they caught it.
Class Action Park and I got on stage
making a comedy movie about the guy who
ran that park and they'd set New Jersey,
but they're filming it in South Africa
because there's so many.
A lot of shit in South Africa,
so cheap to film in South Africa,
so they're building a whole fucking
thing.
Russell Peters just got back from South
Africa.
He was filming a new show for Netflix
called the Indian detective.
He's filming in South Africa,
I think for the same reasons.
They just film a lot of stuff in South
Africa now because of the so cheap.
They're really.
I remember being there and um,
we were,
when we went out there for wildboys is a
dangerous.
Johannesburg is the car jacking capital
of the world.
Oh.
Which we thought was hilarious.
We're jacking off in cars the whole time
working capital of the world.
I thought it was jersey.
Wasn't there like a,
a movie on that,
like drive.
Was there a movie about car jacking and
Camden affiliate?
Camden,
New Jersey.
But they,
what did they say?
A Cape Town is a first world city and a
third world country,
I think.
Does that makes sense?
So,
uh,
in Johannesburg is more Hansberger I
think is a little gnarlier that's more
kind of Lebanon kind of deal.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
That was the impression I got was it was
creepier.
I want to go to Africa,
but I'm scared of malaria.
So funny.
I used to a dump out my malaria pills
and fill up the bottle of Xanax.
What?
You weren't worried about malaria.
Now the quote,
because the malaria pills give you like
terrible nightmares are no crazy
hallucinations.
Like I didn't like the experience in
malaria pills.
Would it do for you?
Give you nightmares?
Yeah.
Gave me fucked up nightmares if I,
if I remember right,
I didn't.
And I was like,
oh,
well I can bring tons of pills and just
put them in the wrong bottle.
Will never get malaria.
Then what?
I don't know.
That's another thing,
man,
that uh,
when I was a kid at the American school
in London,
like in eighth grade,
we went on a field trip to Egypt and um,
they told us,
they said,
don't fucking drink the water.
Don't like,
uh,
even if the order is soda,
don't let them give you ice cubes to
Port [inaudible] the,
you'll get so sick from the water.
And uh,
and we took it seriously.
But then we were eating out Ted,
this restaurant on,
uh,
on the River Nile.
Here's this Egyptian dude fucking
watched and Duncan toothbrush.
And the river now is sitting there
brushing his teeth and I was thinking,
well if the tap water so bad then what's
the river?
Nile has got to be insane.
But I remember at a and I was 13 and I
thought,
well fuck,
if that guy or that guy went to America,
that guy went to England,
the toothbrush,
dude,
he'd probably get sick drinking the
water where I live.
I mean,
I don't know.
It's like whatever your exposure is it,
this has built up his immune system.
He can do that.
And I remember thinking it's probably
the best thing you could do would be to
travel the whole world and drink fucking
tap water like crazy everywhere you go.
That'd be the way to build up your
immune system.
And then ultimately that's what we did.
Wildboys we went to fucking every God
damn continent except Antarctica
Adjunct.
First thing I did in front of them from
the airport and check in the hotel room
and I would put down my bag and I'd
fucking brush my teeth.
You know,
you brush your teeth and he'd been
rented out and then you think.
And I,
and I'd put my head and out of the tap
and it's gulp,
Gulp,
gulp,
and drink a ton of tap water.
I did that all over the,
all over Africa.
Fucking Asia,
South America everywhere I fucking drank
tap water.
Let's get some other fucker.
Had a little bit of diarrhea in Kenya
but bad on.
I don't think that that was a,
that big of a deal.
And I think that,
that,
um,
the,
that my theory was,
was a sound.
I like how you experiment on yourself.
He brought somebody with you.
Mike.
Drink the water
right now,
dude.
Like that's.
Yeah,
it's wider.
Understand Germaphobes and shit like
that.
That's crazy.
You live in an incubator,
that's how you get sick,
you know,
you want to like,
I don't get nervous about shaking
people's hands or no shit like that.
Fuck that.
That's keeping your immune system on it.
Yeah.
No,
of course of a weekend I'll shake
hundreds of people's hands.
Sure.
You know,
at a comedy show,
especially if I have a meet and greet
after the show,
which I didn't do in Dallas this past
weekend.
But for people that are asking fucking
unbelievable,
6,000 people,
I can do it.
Congratulations.
Thanks man.
That was fucking cool.
Thank you.
It's fun.
It's fucking awesome.
I just saw it.
I saw this morning.
I know you're a tour guide.
I'm jealous of your tour.
Scheduled to go like three days and then
I'm home for.
That's how I do it.
I can't do any.
I have kids.
I don't want to do it any other way.
I do two days.
Come back.
Bert Kreischer schedule.
Oh,
he's crazy.
He's fucking hilarious.
So Bert Kreischer would go and do things
on the road for months at a time in a
television show the entire fucking year.
You guys never have.
Well for his television show was real
bad,
but.
And he's not doing that television show
anymore,
which I think is great because it allows
them to concentrate on a standup,
which is another thing.
It's like that was kind of his honeypot
was the his travel channel show.
Whereas it was kind of taken away from a
standup,
but now a standard was blowing up
because he's really focusing on.
And he's doing it a touring a lot
and now people are getting a chance to
enter.
It's tighter too,
like you see him on stage,
it's fucking super tight because he's
performing a lot,
would go a long time without performing
because he'd be doing all this crazy
shit on the road.
Right.
So she enjoyed,
you know,
it's so fun.
I love them too.
Like I did his podcast and we had,
we had a blast and he really encouraged
me is like a man,
go to the store,
go to the store.
And I've been going to the store a lot
and,
and he,
he encouraged me to do that.
That's awesome.
I just think it's funny how you say
that,
uh,
his standup separate because of the
travel channel show,
but now he's on the road and like
everyday out of the year it's like where
does his family fit in?
He's not really mean.
He's home during the weekdays a lot.
It's weekends.
Why?
Yeah.
But he's on the comedy club grind.
So that means he doesn't night.
That's the way it works with me.
My kids are asleep by the time I leave
the house because my sets at the comedy
store always like 10,
15.
I put my kids to bed at eight and then
I'll go over my material real quick and
head out the door and then,
you know,
it's like I have another life,
have the nighttime life.
It's,
it's doable.
It's doable,
but the travels of fucking grind,
man,
it's just,
it's so bad
for your body.
I'm not touring as much as I,
as I did the last few week on week off.
Yeah.
I think on week off,
week on week off as a way to do it.
Two weekends out of the month is enough.
It's more than enough because like if I
come home,
like yesterday I was wrecked when I come
home just just for the weekend of
traveling and then the flight Ensonata
fucking long flight.
Dallas is only two and a half hours or
something.
It's nothing but you get home and you're
like,
oh,
you just said so dragon.
But what you gotta do is work out.
That's the key.
When you get home from something like
that,
go on a hike,
do something to get your metabolism
pumped up,
and then you'll feel normal.
It's the only way to feel normal.
If you feel jet lagged.
A lot of people just like to lay around,
do nothing.
You can't do that.
You've gotta you gotta kickstart your
body.
Just got a blog.
All the carbon can meditate too.
That'll help too.
Don't worry about people fucking with
you,
Steven.
I nowadays,
thanks for setting me straight like
that.
No problem,
man.
I felt I got to have pharmacy staff said
what if had talked about hookers so
much.
He didn't.
I know or whatever.
That's the hooker stories are so fucking
ancient care.
It's just that I have a girlfriend now
and I'm really.
She's just wonderful,
wonderful person and I'd hate for her to
feel bad.
I'd hate for her tabby.
Negative.
Negatively impact.
I'm not saying anything.
Who Cares?
I'll go ahead and tell her,
hey,
I taught some old hooker stories now.
Like,
who cares?
You're just sensitive.
But then,
um,
yeah,
one reason why you like to snuggle.
You're a good guy.
I really want to be good.
My girl,
you know,
and I really,
I really care about being good to my
girl.
So I'd say that's kind of in my head and
then I'm.
And I'm like,
wow,
the floods,
you know,
I'm like,
ah,
I don't want to Lynch our magic over.
Then kind of fucking,
you know,
I mean,
I told the story objective really I a of
what happened in Nigeria,
like want to just,
I just want to say fucking be a Dick to
Allah.
Magical.
He's,
he gets in his own way with that stuff,
you know,
it's in its own way,
but God,
he's a fucking talented guy watching
special.
He's a great guy.
Give Him,
give him love.
And a fellow,
and I have been friends since he first
started doing standup.
I worked with them in the late nineties
at cobb's in San Francisco.
If anybody's listening and they're like,
you know,
maybe just throw,
throw out a tweet and say,
hey,
fucking Steve.
Oh fuck.
Sends his love sentences lab.
I really do.
I genuinely fucking good for you,
dude.
You fucking.
Where can people see you?
They want to go see you shaped.
My next Gig is in Salt Lake City
wiseguys.
Oh,
that's great.
Cool.
I wonder if you had tickets can be my
sixth time there.
I'd love it if,
if.
If I'm in the one of the Green Valley.
Is it called her?
I don't know which one I'm going to.
I don't know which one.
Which in July.
Salt Lake City.
I love that.
Fucking Salt Lake City is a great
fucking place.
People have it all goofy.
Well,
they have it.
They have it in their head that Salt
Lake City is like stuck a mormons,
but the people that come out to the
comedy clubs,
the people that are tired of the
Mormons.
Sure they're fun.
Or the people that are Mormons.
That could take a joke.
I've done so.
I've done so phenomenally well there.
I mean,
I really think I'd been there five times
and I think I'm going back for my sixth
time.
Joey ideas was the first person to tell
me.
He's like,
Joe Rogan,
you've got to get done that fucking Salt
Lake City.
Those motherfuckers are starving.
They're starving for comedy.
I love it.
And what?
What the fuck outside after that,
I'm not even.
I can.
Everything's that.
Steve O.com.
[inaudible] DOT com.
We're excited.
I'm filming a cameo for this.
A movie on Netflix called game over man.
What is it?
Oh No,
no,
but I think seth rogen producing it.
Cool.
It's Netflix original.
Isn't it interesting that Netflix is
doing all these original movies now too?
Like he keeps seeing what the fuck are
they coming up?
I was talking to her about how they're
giving away so much millions of a
dollars to comedians for.
It's great.
It was.
It was cracking up.
He was like,
what am I good time to get into comedy.
It's very good.
Yeah.
All right.
Thanks brother.
Hey,
thanks for a fun podcast time.
I appreciate it greatly.
I appreciate you too brother.
Thank you.
Alright,
we'll be back tomorrow with Graham
Hancock.
Michael Shermer and Randall Carlson is
the big epic debate about a asteroidal
impacts and the end of the ice age and
all that crazy shit.
She'd be a lot of fun.
That's tomorrow.
One 30 PM Pacific Siop.